what's up guys I'm excited today we got
a special gentlemen in studio and this
gentleman that's going to come in as a
man named Eddie Bravo and he's a
Brazilian jiu-jitsu champion he's a
musician
he's a comedy writer
he used to you know [ __ ] with a lot of
hot chicks over but it's a strip club
he's a he was a DJ he has like a nice
kind of you know complexion and
everything he has like a Ecuadorian type
of you know kind of like a style to his
skin what else you know he's he is a
also people talk about him in the
conspiracy space you know people think
oh do you think you know some time do
you think that um you know olives are
from you know another planet or
something like that people will have
crazy ideas about vegetables or seitan
or anything and he has all you know he's
all he's in there you know this guy's
kind of a liaison to the dark arts if
you will you know he's definitely out
there Valda Morton a little bit are
definitely out there you know licking on
Voldemort's navel a little bit in that
space and I want to tell you the mad
master Eddie Bravo when he's the kind of
guy you start talking to him and he goes
you know he's kind of like a puppy you
know he's like a beautiful conspiracy
theorist Brazilian Jiu Jitsu master
musical you know beautiful artist type
of puppy you know he's keyed up like
that young pup so you you know you break
him you to let him out that you know you
let him out the cage into a intro into
it with a question and he just you know
it'll take you nine minutes to get him
back in the car and but I'm so excited
to have him here today and what else
oh this episode is brought to you by
Ridge wallet dot-com now Ridge wallet is
a special type of wallet that you it
sits in your front pocket it's in your
front carry
you know some you know a lot of animals
carry their young in their belly that's
front carry you don't see an animal that
carries its and that carries its babies
in its butt that'd be insane and that's
just like us with our money a lot of us
these days are carrying our money in our
butt and that's not like somebody you
know that's not supposed to be gross or
anything that's just somebody with a
wallet but now the new ridge while it
goes in the front of your pants
that's that front carry what do you have
in your carry you know I'm tired of
carrying around a bunch of extra stuff
in my wallet so I got some nice
accoutrements now just the basics no
more receipts no more dirty condoms you
know no more tickets to Cirque de Soleil
that I never used the freebies and [ __ ]
real stuff only that's more that's
what's in my wallet RS oh and you can go
to the ridge you can go to Ridge wallet
calm slash Theo and you get 10% off and
today we're going to give a nice Ridge
backpack and Ridge wallet to our guests
and you can get everything you want over
there Ridge wallet calm slash Theo the
link is below
I want to thank fear Supply Company for
this beautiful shirt right here and it's
a clothing company based out of Canada
and we'll put that link below and they
got some beautiful Canadian stuff so if
you tired of feeling American in your
shirt or feeling Japanese or however you
feel then you can get this hit as well
as always this episode is brought to you
by gray block pizza the owner of gray
block my boy Thomas has a new podcast
out called mod rats you can check that
out if you want to give that a listen
with all that being said ladies and
gentlemen I want to welcome the one and
only mr. Eddie Bravo
I like it when you hear when you hear
your music do you feel like it's like
that that was a different time in your
life you feel like it's just like one of
the cards that kind of just you know
comes across the table every now and
then or how do you feel about it um I'm
making music more than ever really it's
always I've always made music I never I
never stopped I've always been about the
music really it's just that no one wants
to hear it yeah I came to my whole my
whole life I was you know an aspiring
rock star my whole life since at the age
of 10 my family all the friends I grew
up with down in Orange County in Santa
Ana they all knew me as a guy trying to
make it music you know when I was in and
when I was 21 I finally made the move I
thought I outgrew the Orange County
scene out there because you were getting
big you were getting kind of no it's
just that I was I felt like I was if I
really wanted to make it I had to live
right in Hollywood yeah and you know at
16 and 17 I'd be driving up to Hollywood
on the weekends and partying right on
sunset sunset during the heyday of metal
you know like in the eighties and when
the party was on the streets you know
what I mean everything was overflowing
the rainbow was overflowing the Roxy
gazzarri's which is now the Key Club
with the whiskey all those clubs like in
the front I'm on the sidewalk was just
packed and mobbed with people and dudes
and in sky boo spandex with big ass hair
flyering the streets yes the party was
on the street so me and my buddies would
drive up and we would just walk up and
down the street looking for girls you
know were 16 yes and we had long hair
were fully in you know we were into the
eat metal scene we were like in the
Slayer in Metallica and like the German
thrash scene but girls didn't know that
girls just saw the long hair look Oh
Heath guns and roses like yeah yeah I'm
Guns and Roses whatever I'm poison
whatever you want yeah you know I'm not
gonna explain to him like the different
levels of metal yeah so it's just I just
I was just one appalled Jeffries podcast
but carry the other day from Slayer oh
really yeah
holy [ __ ] were you slayer fan I wasn't a
slayer fan what kind of music do I grew
up listening like rodney james do though
okay so dia grew up listening like did
you go to roses metallica that was an
Aerosmith alright um Jay metalhead you
were kind of a metalhead in the rock oh
that was the first thing yeah I mean my
brother or not my brother and I used to
fistfight to Slayer songs he used to put
them on and then we he would beat me up
basically so seeing Carrie that's the
first thing I told him I was like hey
man my brother used to fistfight to your
music yeah man um the music industry had
me hook line and sinker man I was
chasing the mansions and the hoes I was
thought my whole life was all about
getting that mansion partying like David
Lee Roth having 50 chicks around me I
was chasing that [ __ ] they got me hooked
MTV got me I was watching MTV on my I
want bad [ __ ] you know so I eventually
got pour some sugar on me like that kind
of those yeah my goal was to move to
Hollywood
yeah and get some strippers to support
me in my musical endeavors you know what
I mean have him buy me groceries I heard
the stores like the Motley Crue's
stories where there were there were
whenever first blowing up in Hollywood
they'd have all these strippers bringing
them groceries they didn't work all they
did it was write music all day that was
the lifestyle that I wanted right they
got me man they brainwashed me oh I was
hooked and by the time I figured out you
know I thought it was really easy to
make it in the music business cuz at 13
maybe at 12 or 13 there was a band
called Queens right yeah they had a song
called silent who said it yes yes yes
that was whenever huge right but in the
very beginning they released an EP with
the song queen of the Reich on it and
just one song blew him up so I thought
oh [ __ ] all you need is one good song
and you automatically blow
right that's what I really believe I
believe that if you have one good song
he will blow up you can make it happen
and so did you and so that kind of so
you figured that so as far as you in
your mind at that point you're like oh
well yeah I can make each other things
happen yeah just gotta make one good
scene yeah one good song and by the time
I realized that that's not how the music
business work it was too late I dug
myself in way too deep
what with the drugs have partying in the
pond well I wasn't really into drugs I
drank I was always I was always drinking
I'm Mexican and you know that's uh it's
pretty normal for Mexicans but um I was
never into coke and I didn't smoke weed
at the totally against weed didn't do
coke didn't do you know heroin or crack
or anything like that every now and then
if I was trying to hook up with the girl
and she was like a speed freak and yeah
really really get a little bit in you
yeah you know what they bust out the
little crystal method line I'm like I
would do it if it meant getting [ __ ]
yeah back when I was sixteen and
seventeen and eighteen I would do it and
you know always regretted it I know you
have the energy of your twenty men yeah
you know and and it only lasts for like
a day and then you you have to pay for
it and then you're gonna sleep for two
days straight yeah and it always sucks
they come down that come down man never
never wanted to do it again I never it
was never like damn them I feel like
[ __ ] give me some more crystal maybe it
was like I will never do that [ __ ] ever
again and then like a year later some
vagina would come along and she's you
know dude that's a vagina look vaginas a
gateway drug people don't realize that
you know just like I say hanging drywall
carpentry is a gateway drug to doing
drugs
you don't meet somebody who does drywall
that doesn't also do you know speed
doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense but it's never
put on that scale you see like oh well
weed is a gateway drug
dude vagina is a gateway drug and also
carpentry and hanging drywall every one
of my buddies I guess didn't survive all
I got a bit no but everyone I'm a year
later is in a a man you know so I moved
to Hollywood at 21 and so we now you say
you were hook line into it at that point
you were hook line in Hollywood you
wanted that dream I had to I realized
that it was
more than one song yeah I didn't really
I didn't realize exactly how the music
business work I thought it was just
gonna be really easy people would tell
me like my uncle told me you know they
didn't want me to move to Hollywood it's
not like 45 minutes they thought I will
magazine Family Circus is a job so they
thought I was moving to [ __ ] England
and my uncle tom is you know do you
realize it it's it's a one-in-a-million
shot that you're gonna make him the
music business and I thought I was that
one-in-a-million
I was a [ __ ] idiot you know okay well
at that moment at that point you're an
idiot or you're like but you have to
have some of that right yeah you gotta
you gotta be an idiot you know if you
think yeah just gonna make it in the
music business and I really thought I
really thought it was a hundred percent
I thought it was a matter of [ __ ]
time I thought was he chosen one yeah it
was beyond comp I knew for sure and then
every every Christmas or Thanksgiving I
come back and visit my family they're
like how's the music Edgar how's the new
demo there was always a new demo I
always had a new demo a new band it was
like it was like they note they actually
saw me live once I brought my whole
family my aunt's and and it was horrible
it was like a worse Slayer you can
imagine yeah and you know a shitty club
and Santa Fe Springs called checks and
we played with sacred Reich and a sacred
Rite was signed and and you know it was
a big gig for us but we were horrible
yes and my aunt's just Mexican
disappointed on and there's all these
long you know Dia de los Muertos it's a
dark night when you have a near they're
like damn they want they were they were
trying to plan an intervention to get me
out of me as if that means don't wait
you're this you're you're very smart you
can go what are you doing and then they
finally just gave up on me like [ __ ]
I went to Hollywood now were you
influenced by like la bomb or any of
that like that type of stuff no now
no I I probably listen to a hundred
thousand hours of mariachis oh my and I
can tell one song from the next really I
don't know one vocal melody or nothing
you would think I would know the [ __ ]
sass and who the singers were yeah I was
just pumped for arted with it but I
never retain not even one song I don't
you don't want that there was no
attraction I didn't retain I couldn't
tell the difference from one mariachi
song to the next yeah you know it was a
Louis something my mom was sewing to my
mom wanted to be a singer when she was
younger so anytime we go to a Mexican
restaurant they have a mariachi my mom's
gonna get up I'll sing like that goddamn
mariachi you know she that's awesome
yeah no it was a kid then did you see
her doing that you think that inspired
you at all in a weird way or no no I
maybe subconsciously but what really
inspired me was in 1978 the kiss movie
that was on NBC called kiss Meets The
Phantom of the park and it was right
when you know there's like early kiss 73
74 75 or you know everyone's like yeah
like early kiss but then once they blew
up and 76 77 they got really bubblegummy
and then on the hardcore fans you know
they kind of died like all bands yes
like vanilla ice was hot for one [ __ ]
here and then he went MC Hammer was the
hot thing then it's embarrassing to say
you like MC Hammer right it was getting
like that I got into kiss when it was
embarrassing for teenagers to say they
like kiss but I was eight so I didn't
know I didn't know what he's telling I
didn't know and you weren't even sound
at that point is an eight year old
you're still like people were like holy
[ __ ] this it was like kiss yeah kiss was
so over and dead by the time that TV
movie came out to the hardcore fans that
I was a and I didn't know anything about
kiss but I was talking [ __ ] on kids at
school because the night that muli aired
at school the kids were talking to
eight-year-olds we're talking about the
kiss well you're gonna see the new kiss
movie tonight and everyone's like [ __ ]
kids eight-year-olds is no [ __ ] because
their older brothers and my stepdad was
a classic rock guy and he couldn't stand
kiss okay him he was into my GLAAD
Zeppelin and and kiss was just bubblegum
[ __ ] yeah at that point that's not
this the stuff that was he cool did he
have a mustache what kind of stepdad was
he was a total douchebag he was evil but
he did
like classic rock got me into Van Halen
you know so Ted Nugent The Pretenders
just get on and on he that's the gifts
of a step that usually just a little bit
of music and some pants or something you
know you know what when he took off he
beat my mom and took off he left his
stereo oh there we go we couldn't touch
his stereo you know when he was when he
you know if he wasn't around we'd play a
record understand it was so weird cuz I
didn't understand stereo I didn't know
there was a left speaker and a right
speaker cuz I had a little turntable
with one speaker right so when you don't
realize that you're missing half the
music and the guitar riffs and [ __ ] on
that are playing on the other side so
whenever I play kiss records on hysteria
when he's at work a whole other world
like what the [ __ ] is what all these
other riffs going on I was only hearing
one guitar it was so weird why I didn't
get it I didn't get what stereo was and
that so stepdad left some good stuff you
know he left to treat some music you're
into music when the kiss movie came out
we talked [ __ ] on kiss the whole time
everybody did in school but me and my
brother we were like we it was eight
o'clock Friday night NBC we [ __ ] turn
that thing on like oh [ __ ] and I'm my
mom my mom is cool cuz usually at 8
o'clock she got the TV she was watching
her novellas yeah yeah Spanish soap
operas and she was watching the viviana
at that time she's like she's she knew
how important this was just but we were
talking [ __ ] on kiss but there was so
much hype we had to watch this movie saw
the movie rock and roll all night blew
my [ __ ] mind
and I just I wanted to be a rock star as
soon as I saw that movie and went to gym
Co which was like a Walmart back in the
day with my aunts and like remember you
ever see a South Park when Cartman wants
to get a toy and drags his mom and he's
the boss and he's looking yeah oh yeah
you know I mean it was like that I had
to get rock and roll all night and party
there I had to get that goddamn song so
we went marched in the gym Co went to
the record apartment dragged my aunt and
we were just went through the KISS
records and I found rock and roll all
night and it was on the kiss a live
album and uh I didn't know what a live
record is my hand goes I think this is a
concert record
what shut up it's a record or records of
record so got it home put the needle on
and then the audience you know hear that
it's a live record of that what the [ __ ]
is this a football game I didn't get I
didn't know what a live record was so
then you're getting up so it's
interesting man it's like you get these
little bitty doses of like the whole
musical world you get you know first you
you get one half of you get mono and
then you get stereo and that kind of
blows your mind and then you get the
audience level it's almost like it came
in at doses that were like you know for
a guy that seems like as active brained
as you are and this is just some
judgement for me I don't know you but a
guy seems as active brained as you are
like that's almost how you need it in
order for it to like you know piece by
piece for it to kind of you know yeah I
was an inch by inch type of thing and
you know from that point on the only
other thing the only other thing I was
into was being a football player I
wanted to be I was really into football
and I thought okay it's gonna be I'm
gonna be a rock star and or a football
player and um you know in 1979 I'm nine
years old I'm playing tackle football
junior all-america I'm playing [ __ ]
middle linebacker defensive end you know
everyone's the same size I didn't
realize that I was gonna stop growing
I didn't realize Mexicans don't play
football yeah I didn't realize I really
thought I was gonna be a [ __ ] I could
be a professional football player like a
lot of Mexican men and women are the
same height like is there a certain what
how tall are Mexicans is there one
height no five four okay cuz I see some
bro and I also see like I used to see if
they if you leave a street light on dude
Latinos will end up kissing under it I
noticed that we don't play football you
know we play soccer football yeah not
like American football once I realized
that I went in at sixth grade was the
first taste of like maybe because in my
neighborhood were playing street
football and I was a [ __ ] star right
you know with other Mexicans right but
once I went to school play tackle in the
fourth and fifth grade and then went to
sixth grade there wasn't tackle in the
sixth grade Ryan it was a flag football
so you didn't play you didn't put the
pads back on till high school so I
didn't make it that's when in sixth
grade I was too slow and I blamed it on
the fact that it was flag football my
[ __ ] flag football
wait till ninth grade when we played
tackle football show you what the [ __ ] I
want a team ball a junior all-american
[ __ ] and a peewee football
aza I was a little star in peewee
football but I in the sixth grade you
start to separate you know and then in
seventh grade again I didn't make the
goddamn football team so do you got are
you new Rosie just not any good at it
I was um Mexicans can't run fast really
no no we could jump fences like a
[ __ ] I do that I could climb a
tree but just the whole track where
fences you guys would cruise yeah yeah
so I realized it's not gonna happen for
me a foot boom
so football was out and so then your
life is not music it was just music at
that point and it started let my mind
let my hair grow got really in the
Slayer and writing satanic lyrics and
[ __ ] I bought like a Satanic Bible what
were you doing the work behind the
scenes because it sounds like you have
all the accoutrements you know what I'm
saying you got the hair you know what's
going on you're tuned in with music are
you playing any music oh absolutely but
the the first band I put together it was
called the bikers it was we were gonna
come out on stage with our BMX bikes
yeah and then it's then it switched a
tight action and then it switched to
execrate which is to put under a curse
Jesus and at that point all my first the
Dark Arts at some point it sound like it
was the violent it was evil at 13 I was
writing satanic lyrics and [ __ ] and I
started playing drums only because
everybody else in the band all my
friends they already had guitars and no
one no one had a drumset so I thought
and I could air drum - I love it loud by
Kissick so I figured I could play drums
right I'm like oh I could pack a play
drums uh-huh yeah I just start playing I
started playing drums just because no
one else would okay and then I I started
taking drum lessons and my drum teacher
this was changed everything from my drum
teacher I show up to his house to take a
drum lesson and yeah he had a guitar
acoustic guitar on his bed and even
though the only reason I play drums is
because no one else would once you start
playing drums or whatever once you start
playing bass that's the best interest
instrument you know the drums were the
best so he had a guitar and I kind of
felt like betray
why you [ __ ] playing a guitar man and
I'm taking lessons from here you know
what I mean yeah
stabbing me in the [ __ ] back like
that and he said listen in the music
business the drummer is always at the
mercy of the songwriter of the band you
know it's not gonna be like that for me
I'm gonna write that the music I'm gonna
write the lyrics I'm gonna be one of
those drummers and I thought holy [ __ ]
so am i I don't want to be at the mercy
of someone else yeah so at that point I
bought a guitar and even though I was
playing drums all through the 80s I was
writing the music writing the lyrics
because of what my drum teacher told me
Brian Johnson never forget that guy that
was he said the drummer is always at the
mercy of the of the writer the
songwriter like you know there's very
few bands where the drummer is the lead
singer or not even the lead singer or
just who writes the music right who
arranges it who puts it together who
produces it's rarely the drummer the
drummer's just like like a hired gun
generally yeah the least important guy
in the band yeah and that's just like
that actually
oh yeah exactly Neil Peart he writes all
the lyrics yes we used to play the drums
use a big inspiration to me yeah yeah
for sure so that one drum lesson that
[ __ ] changed everything so from that
point on I always wrote the music not
all of it we I would write with you know
the guitar players of the band like
James he was he was one of my you
collaborate well with others because you
seem like kind of like a are you go are
you are you a guy that you know you'd
like to kind of create it just on your
own well it's a good question this is
the way I've worked in the bands the
bands I was in I would I would I didn't
want to be a dick mm-hmm so I said I
would say the rules of the band are
anybody in the band can write and
contribute but if you bring a riff into
the van or a little part if one of the
guys in the band doesn't like it we're
gonna [ __ ] chop it out yeah we're not
gonna use it
we're only gonna use your [ __ ] and
everybody in the band likes it it's
pretty fair right it's fair enough it's
not democratic and people that don't
write in the band they realize you know
you we gotta get on stage and play this
in front of people so you you want to
[ __ ] force your riff that nobody
likes we're gonna be on stage playing it
the audience they gonna like it either
right so real quick that understanding
everyone knows that role like okay this
guy writes all the cool riffs that the
audience likes so it's better if we play
his room
yeah that's a pretty solid formula and
so how did that work with the bands it
worked pretty well right it worked great
so the way I would write music was
anybody who wanted to give me riffs they
gave me a tape my yeah the two guitar
I'd be the drummer and the two guitar
players would give me tapes of all like
ten reps 15 rips there you check them
out I would check them all out and I
would have like a song like a skeleton
for a song and then I would take the
riffs that I would like and I would
stick it in and I would record the whole
song on a four track and so I would have
a whole shitty production but here's the
whole song let's duplicate that and the
guitar players would listen to it and
they wait for their riff oh [ __ ] there's
my real cool so they'd be happy about
that's cool and they'd be happy that I
actually had the skills to arrange it
and put it all together do the work yeah
you're showing back up with some people
love that yeah so and they knew that if
I really liked something it was a good
riff and then everybody else was gonna
like it nice so they only so after a
while they trusted me to behead it all
together so I was always putting
together this stuff and I probably wrote
half the lyrics and and my my buddy
James he wrote he was really good at
writing lyrics too so we wrote lyrics
together sometimes he would write the
chorus of the song and I would write the
verses of the song and I would just put
it together and arrange everything and
the songs were long too back then it was
cool to write eight-minute songs 10
minute songs yeah
Metallica oh yeah I saw that we're going
forever Master of Puppets you know eight
minute song is not uncommon you know oh
no there were some songs I remember um
I'm a couple songs that lasted I felt
like a third of my childhood you know
like there were some songs that were
like not you know something you get a
song there's 14 minutes on a on a
cassette tape I got burned burnt out
really quick writing speed metal stuff
is just like after the same I think
after a while just the drumbeat just you
know I started getting burnt out and you
can't play it a lot of places like you
know you play it like I mean there's no
girls at the shows it's been like what
the [ __ ] am i doing because that music
office or that mansion you know and
they're broke and the bass players are
sleeping on couches
well they do a lot of them end up
without the metal and just on speed
yeah exactly anyway aura speed metals a
gateway drug and um you know hip-hop was
was blowing up at the in the 80s too and
I loved the concept of rap I loved I
loved that in rock you had to be
metaphoric and you had to be poetic and
vague and I get like what are these
songs really about you had to but in rap
you could be that and funny super
violent you could be straight out you
there was no limit in rap ok loved that
but I didn't I wasn't really into the
music but will you cheat liked it and
not chase him but do you feel like were
you aiming to be a star do you feel like
because I know the first part you said
because I wonder sometimes like when I
came to Hollywood like or what I wanted
to be you know I know wanted to do
stand-up and I don't know maybe
somewhere in my head I wanted to be you
know part of I don't know if I wanted to
be part of Hollywood I guess somewhere
in my mind I wanted to be popular you
know like because the first part you
mentioned about the about the speed
metal and stuff for the rock is that you
know about the the mansions and the
girls you know and wanting that
lifestyle maybe that's it we did you
feel like you were kind of chasing like
a lifestyle a little bit what was some
motivation man I cuz I was I was the
most insecure kid I was a product of my
father my real father didn't give a [ __ ]
about me yeah didn't give a [ __ ] he had
19 kids that was one of my keys he would
just [ __ ] everybody and getting
everyone pregnant so did you just
running the kids that looked like you
sometimes you like what ha ha ha no no
no it wasn't like that it looked like my
mom really so you know oh so that was my
mom my mom had three kids I was one but
did you feel like kind of blessed you
look like your mom since your dad had so
many kids did you ever think about her
since he was so ugly but um yes so with
the rap thing this is this is how the
music evolved um I I like the concept of
rap but I didn't like musically where
the rap was coming from how I really
wasn't into funk or like James Brown or
George Clinton wasn't into that [ __ ]
yeah but then I heard Public Enemy
collaborate with anthrax and they did it
like a like a speed metal rap song noise
once I heard that I mean one DMC was
already mixing rock and rap and I kind
of dug that for them
see more like they were like ac/dc
making rap and I wasn't at that point I
was full-blown like speed metal so I
thought that was cool
ac/dc was cool Run DMC was cool but then
the collaboration between anthrax and
Public Enemy that's what got me and
right in the middle of me like not
knowing what the [ __ ] I wanted to do
what sound like do I do I want to write
another speed metal song I thought [ __ ]
there needs to be a whole band like this
like a speed metal rap type band so
that's where you went now that's that
was next so that that was the big move
the big move was I'm going I'm gonna
move to [ __ ] Hollywood sell my drums
I'm already right into music I'm gonna
play guitar and I'm gonna make a part
rap part metal part electronic part
gothic and just mix up a bunch of stuff
like the anthrax Public Enemy
collaboration didn't have sin because I
was I was getting secretly I was into
getting getting into the Cure and
Depeche Mode and Nine Inch Nails you
know album so I was really getting into
like a goth II kind of cool simpie sound
and I was doing that secretly because
you can't really hear into Slayer you
can't tell people you a cure [ __ ]
kill you you know back in the 80s were
you like so what did the other speed
metal guys think when you're like you
brought a couple brothers into the staff
you know what we're adding in right now
what happened was my guitar player James
his black guy oh he was he was my guitar
player in the speed metal project we
formed our speed metal band together me
and him were the main songwriter but on
that but then we had another guitar
player and a drum another guitar player
bass player and a singer so we did me
and James I said hey let's let's do a
side project will do like a hip hop side
project but we'll do like [ __ ] wood
not typical hip hop music we'll make hip
hop for people who don't like hip hop
you know for the alternative and we
didn't we made a demo teams it was
garbage it was a verse attack it was
garbage but we liked I liked moving that
way so I basically produced all the
music and James the guitar player he
became the rapper cuz it turns out he'd
like to rap and I didn't know that I
thought he was a pure like metal black
dude so you guys we're all hiding your
true selves exactly I'm like you like
[ __ ] rappers like yeah but he felt
since he was black and in the metal
scene he had to be a super encyclopedia
on metal cuz you had to be respected
yeah cause like you know what there
wasn't that many black people in
Speedman yeah I think there's just hey
it was like four you know what I mean
Katyn de Pena the singer for hyrax he
was respected because he knew so much
about the history of speed metal and
hardcore and punk and all that the
people like okay he's cool now so it's
like so with music then I mean it seemed
like you just kind of as you like
something you just take it right into
whatever you're then creating it yeah I
was getting really yeah I was the only
reason I got into speed metal is because
we were shitty musicians and so [ __ ]
me doesn't convey splat you can play
speed man yeah do speed will do punk
hide your [ __ ] yeah you know what I mean
you know especially you can't do like a
serious rock song you need serious
vocals and you need professional
arrangements you need people who really
know what the [ __ ] so did you like music
or were you good at music I just wanted
to be a rock star and and when you suck
you play [ __ ] that you're just
disguising yourself you're disguising
your inability to say yeah and play by
just screaming and yelling and mics yeah
but then as I got better at my guitar
and got better at putting together songs
then we started bringing in like I
remember getting my first real vocalist
at first lead vocals still the speed
model man he actually knew how to sing
like Rob Halford and he was really good
like Bruce Dickinson from Iron Man
he was really good so I learned a lot
from him like [ __ ] the singer we had
before it was just like like a punk
singer doing thrash yeah I was just a
stepson somebody that my son we're doing
harmonies and [ __ ] like [ __ ] that's cool
you're doing two different keys and two
different pictures and making him work
together I didn't really notice that
[ __ ] before so then I started evolving
musically and when we did this little
side that little side rap band the rest
of the band like you said they were kind
of like what the [ __ ] you guys do I'm
sure yeah why are you guys leaving like
no no this is just a side project but
meanwhile we're like let's do this
full-time so we decided to move to
Hollywood do forget speed metal one bad
band to make another bad van yeah yeah
but at least this new band that wasn't
speed metal and it was a combination of
rap it
like that the same formula is Linkin
Park yeah break down a Lincoln back it's
part rap part singing a heavy guitar
clean guitar acoustic drums and
electronic drums - since synthetic drums
so they mixed everything keyboards to
that a lot of synth
so that's the same the same formula
that's what you're looking for you know
we did that at 91 members Linkin Park's
for sound came out in 2000 yeah so we're
how that you're ahead of the rail way
before Linkin Park but but anyways but
we were doing it wrong because we were
still had eight-minute songs but key
imagine Linkin Park most of their songs
like three minutes to the point 3
minutes 1 second 2 minutes 53 seconds 3
minutes 11 seconds to the point a nice
short song we were doing the same
formula but nine minutes aggravate 10
minutes yeah which bothering people for
those last six minutes is bothering
exactly exactly but like what inspires
you it's like it gets you pumped up
there's a rap you're right there yeah
get to the point
yes to the point and we didn't because
because I dumped all the speed metal and
I didn't want to go right into three
minute songs I felt like that was too
much of a sellout I already felt like I
was a kind of a sellout leaving speed
metal cuz you feel that yeah like look
at him like there was a lot of a lot of
musicians that were in in thriving speed
metal bands and they would leave I
remember Larry lil on from possessed
they were the most satanic speed metal
band he when he left the band to form a
like like a comical type Red Hot Chili
Peppers type Dan I forget the name of
the band mr. bungle man he did something
and we considered him a sellout look at
this [ __ ] he left speed to do
like a regular band [ __ ] that dude so I
felt a little bit of that too so that's
why I had to keep the songs long are the
respect yeah exactly it was a slow
progression and then eventually that
band now I'm in Hollywood trying to sell
that bad I'm making I'm producing all
the music James my former guitar player
now he's the rapper
yeah and now this is the new band called
blackened kill Symphony Jesus all right
that sounds horrible yeah yeah totally I
mean I don't know bad way but it sounds
like you know I think I was in a band
for I think like a couple days and I was
young and we [ __ ]
sucked and I've never been able to play
anything yeah so I don't know what I was
doing there you know what did you think
yeah sang and I also I would do actually
this is back when they when people used
is gonna sound [ __ ] pretty sad but uh
when people use like triangle and [ __ ]
like heavy triangle though like
tambourine I've said like anything it
was background like the chakras what are
those things called maracas yeah maracas
knockers and so I'm in Hollywood now see
your music so you're in Hollywood you're
doing music but I wanted to be in shape
so I wasn't a fat rock star so I got it
I joined a gym for now wouldn't hire
that though cuz I feel like there's
always this one guy Malmsteen Yngwie
Malmsteen is a famous rock star one of
the greatest guitar players of all time
and then he let himself go and got a
little fat for a while and people
started making fun of him so I wanted to
make sure that I was that I look good on
stage that wasn't [ __ ] so I got into
martial arts so that's where the martial
arts came in okay I started doing karate
you know I did a little the Bruce Lee
system I was doing out you know through
the Danny Inosanto he's out here in West
oh I'm sorry
now West LA I Marina del Rey Danny in a
sauna Bruce Lee student trying to run
his student got into that then I saw UFC
- mm-hmm and I realize it I got to start
doing jiu-jitsu [ __ ] [ __ ] karate do you
think though like your drumming you the
ability to drum did that was it was that
up your hand strength when like your
hand speed or something was there any
like crews over when you were into that
nothing like oh not at all but I did
wrestle a couple years in high school so
one in junior high one year in junior
high and one here in in high school and
I thought that was like just an
insignificant part of my life that would
never have anything to do with my Wow
but once I started doing jiu-jitsu once
I saw that man you could get on the
ground and that's a martial art
wrestling is a martial art I never
looked at wrestling as a martial art to
me it was like one-on-one football let's
try to tackle each other and it almost
sounds like kind of like it fits yours
whatever works for you and your brain
because you know it seems like you know
what the music you're missing your mix
in different styles you're like you know
well here's a fast style and here's like
more of a you know a verbose style and
I'll ear
circle style and you know you're trying
to like kind of fit those two together
yeah yeah you could you could say that I
definitely you saw them to the the mix
you were like oh that's something I
don't know if I ever looked at it that
way but yes I guess you can say my music
and what my jujitsu ended up evolving
into is is like you know the same idea
just a little of everything and trying
to put together like the ultimate
package right that's that's what I'm
trying to do you seem like a really I
mean yeah I mean just listen to you it
seem like you want to
that's interests like you want to be you
love to produce you love to create you
love to to mix and match and like and
also you're involved in it at the same
time yeah you know the music never stops
so I started doing jujitsu and then
eventually the jujitsu blew up but even
right when it blew up when I beat her
the Gracie in 2003 I'm like right away
I'm trying to cuz I already knew that
athletes are not allowed to they're not
given a chance to blow up in music they
just are not right no athlete like no
Shaq Shaq put a CD I bought a CD when I
was young Deion Sanders had an album
exactly rap songs did he really
they're not allowed to be successful in
the music business so I knew that so I
thought wow this is great
that um you know the the jiu-jitsu is
blowing up but [ __ ] that's gonna kill my
music so right away in interviews I
would I would make it clear to people
that listen I'm a I'm a musician I
produce music yeah this [ __ ] was just
some accident right you know what I mean
and actually I was working for Comedy
Central when I beat her the Grace and
this year right now man show I was a
writer for the man show so would there
were those dudes blown out were like
Corolla and we're I mean were they
talking about this cuz this must have
been I mean well well Adam Adam Corolla
and Jimmy Kimmel left the man show like
after five seasons right and he was a
fan huh and Comedy Central wanted to
keep it going so they asked Joe Rogan
that's Joe Rogan if he wanted to take
over and it just so happened that I
thought at that point me and Joe of
hanging out all the time I'm on the road
with them
we're writing comedy together I mean we
had 20 sketches the plan was we were
going to pitch like a sketch of a sketch
show yeah that was the plan
we had the sketches written out we would
we were writing all sorts of [ __ ] did
you guys ever pitch that this is what
happened is out of [ __ ] nowhere
before we got to pitch they called Joe
and they heard Joe was looking for you
know was about to pitch a sketch comedy
show somehow so they contacted him and
said do you want to want to be the new
host for the man show Jimmy Kimmel and
Adam Carolla are leaving and we want to
keep it going
and Joe is like you know all [ __ ] yeah
we're about holy [ __ ] is perfect some
perfect synchronicity pizza show yeah so
that's what happened so Joe calls me up
said guess what dude I'm you know our
plans are [ __ ] happening but the line
and I'm like one goes yeah we're gonna
we're gonna be [ __ ] writing for the
man show and at that point I was making
money DJing at strip clubs
Jesus Wow how was degenerate strip clubs
until my music blew up but at the same
time but at the same time on the side
I was dabbling with comedy only because
growing up it was all about music but
the two things that I would have always
tape on my VCR it was always about the
music but my two favorite things to tape
were boxing and then they became the UFC
UFC replaced boxing but I was obsessed
with box and I was a boxing encyclopedia
in the 80s I would tape everything
boxing Tuesday night fights whatever
whatever
Tuesday night fighters you ever get at
boxing I was I was obsessed with it and
fighting and also anything comedy
especially black calm in living color I
had every episode of the New Living
Color edited together without the
commercial I watched that [ __ ] over you
know I was a huge fan of black comedy
when Hollywood shuffle came out that was
Robert Townsend and never saw that good
Keenen Ivory Wayans the first movie they
they they just maxed out their credit
cards it's like a super low budget movie
called Hollywood shuffle came out 86 on
him with the Lincoln it was only on one
theater in Lakewood a black area I
[ __ ] drove my ass
I heard about I'd watch anything black
comedy I was at one point I thought why
people weren't funny yeah except for Sam
Kinison and and like Blackburn how
George Carlin maybe a little bit but um
I thought you know I was yeah there was
no black there was no white people are
funny when I was Eddie Murphy Richard
Pryor like those guys were the funny
coming in on ergonomic VI tape comicview
like a BT count you I will tape anything
black comedy Def Jam I was obsessed and
I was of so obsessed with comedy because
it's it's an amazing thing where you
could watch someone do an hour and a
half and just crush it it's like way
better than a movie you know like you
get way more entertainment value from
good comedy than you do from beating a
movie I gray for sure so and I was
always fascinated with how do they think
I could I couldn't figure out how they
could take something so simple that
everyone agrees with that's why they're
laughing cuz like yeah that's what I
think too
how come I couldn't think of that I was
fascinated with how the [ __ ] they put
together comedy and I never I never I
could never understand it until 1998
that's when I I the first time I smoked
weed and had a positive experience all
other times smoking weed like once a
year always be a horrible experience I'd
smoke weed at a party and [ __ ] freak
out getting like what happened hi go sit
in the car what so in 1998 I was I was
uh I was in love with the most beautiful
girl I've ever been with at up at that
point
hmm is a girl from white girl trip club
white girl from Kentucky with uh with a
black booty she played soccer her whole
life
her body everyone like like just fell
over with this girl's body little 23
year olds nice titties some Kentuckiana
and everything almost got a scholarship
playing soccer those legs were on point
yeah everybody when they when they see
her they're like oh [ __ ] look at that
body so I fell in love with her
and right right at the beginning she
came on my house one day and pulled out
of joints and the smoker joint on my I
am NOT gonna smoke weed
I hate we yeah I would I was the anti
were you are you're the opposite of weed
almost as a human yeah I was anti we
here I was against it so she pulls this
with this heat she pulls out this this
spliff and then what do you do am I
that I don't want to smoke weed you had
to like she took a took a [ __ ] rip
and I had the most incredible night of
sex
we laughed like mental patients all
night ordered late-night damiano's when
it was around and on Fairfax
you can order pizza yes fun we in the
morning we ordered cheesecake peace
awesome - y'all doing sex or not yeah
but that wasn't really it that the sex
was great everything was great no I'll
[ __ ] anybody on weed yeah thanks anybody
feel like it makes your wife feel like a
different person yeah yeah and then on
the next morning I couldn't I couldn't
believe that had such an amazing time hi
so I couldn't get it so the next we try
to begin the next night and the same
thing we had an amazing time then the
next time then I began to realize like
wait a minute
we doesn't make you paranoid it makes
you whatever you want to make it so the
reason I had a great time is how I fell
in love I was in a great time but you
already in a great time yes so I
realized really quick it was an
amplifier of your emotions do you still
feel that way about absolutely Wow never
thought about it like that amplifier
because physically what it does is I
don't know how it does it but it makes
blood rush to your head yes while your
eyes get bloodshot you have all this
blood in your head and blood is good
blood is life right so if blood is
flooding your brain that must mean that
your brain is flooded with activity and
now we're ready so either it's gonna
[ __ ] make you paranoid cuz you can't
handle all that power or you're gonna
learn how to handle all that power like
neo and the matrix at first seems like
[ __ ] I can't he couldn't fight anybody
but then by matrix 3 he's fighting 50
guys in the sky cuz he got it he got all
that [ __ ] down he mastered the power he
mastered the power some people get they
get scared away by the power too much
blood in the brain they're thinking
about - [ __ ] too much that's what
happens to me yeah and I end up your can
often get scared in my room happens me a
lot of times yeah yeah that so happens
to me too
like if I have something really
stressful going on in my life like a
couple weeks goes a lot of stressful
[ __ ] going on
I wouldn't smell weed yeah I know you
know it's just gonna make me focus on it
too much and I want to not think about
it do you so that was like four or five
days where I wouldn't I wouldn't you
were out I got so high in college one
time that I called the cops on myself
right and people have done this right
it's pretty normal
this is popular for I don't know if it
happens to everybody definitely happens
to white people where like you get high
and call the cops but and there was a
party at our place where everybody's
outside [ __ ] partying so I the
ambulance is coming right so here's what
I did bro I waited till they were coming
in the front and then I came out the
back door and went and got in the
ambulance in the shotgun right oh my god
just wait it came back out of the party
because I don't want to be embarrassed
like being carried out on a stretcher or
anything you know that's crazy I was
still like so self-conscious so I was
just sitting in the ambulance by myself
even though I called it and they come
back and get back in and they're like
hello and I was like yeah I'm the guy
that called let's get the [ __ ] out if
you go I gotta beat some some work I'm
gonna um I want to take Chris Perez is
are our producers here today too and
he's a big fan of yours thank you and
and he's yeah you have any question when
I'm with Chris we're at right now um
yeah you know what I actually got a
question about martial arts okay so you
know a lot of us know you from you like
you know beating Oyler Gracie and also
from you know your coaching Tony
Ferguson one of your students recently
became a UFC champion even though there
was some drama with that
yeah but I'm curious about what are some
of your most notable defeats and what
did you learn from them as both a
competitor and also as a coach new
perspective man I've learned so much
from defeats you know my students
defeats after I beat coiler Gracie in
2003 that was in the middle of a
tournament so wasn't like a like a super
fight or anything that he would he was
the second round of a 16-man tournament
so to win a 60 man term you have to win
four matches and won the first one and
then I ran into hor the Gracie on my
second match beat him and uh in the
third match I got [ __ ] smoked by Leo
Viera who's a multiple time national or
world champion and you weren't even a
black belt that now I was a brown belt
straight so I approached I approached
going to Brazil and doing that
tournament like I had zero to lose I
didn't expect I expected to get stomped
and it was right in the middle of me
more
King on the man show and being super
depressed I was super depressed that
from day one
the producers everybody they would just
they didn't think you had it dick they
didn't want to hire me Joe made them
hire me good cuz Joe Joe said
Joe's right in the middle of Fear Factor
he's a huge star and then he gets asked
to do the show the only reason he
considered it cuz me and him were
already writing sketch we already had
sketches right so he said so he had to
sit down and talk to these guys they
really had to impress him and so he sat
down and had some meetings say listen if
I do this I already got the okay from
NBC they're being really [ __ ] cool
about this they said I could do this
because they have respect for me and
they but I have some conditions
I gotta have green light power on all my
sketches I gotta have veto power and all
the sketches I got to I'm gonna decide
who my host is not not anybody else I
decide who I work with and I'm gonna
bring in my writers and they said okay
okay okay goes and I want I'm gonna hire
the head writer and they said okay okay
so they were basically saying okay
whatever whatever let's do it we're good
so he has a couple dinners and meetings
with different head writers and he
decided on one a guy named my Tom and he
got him hired he said okay I want this
guy this guy's cool yes so he got hired
but he wasn't involved in the
negotiations for the hiring though so
this guy Tom he negotiated an executive
producer point oh so now he signs and he
has more power than Joe technically
right so that's where everything got
[ __ ] yeah so um he is a head writer
and he's got he can hire nine riders you
know nine riders so they sat Joe side of
the contract and once he signed they're
like we got this mofo yeah chase on your
shows out of your hands on yeah yeah so
they said okay Joe there's how we're
gonna do it yeah he had three guys he
won a tire Chris Maguire
Matty Kirsch who were working comics and
I thought no Matty yeah at that point I
was doing like like open mic night I
wasn't really like but you felt like he
had your back you mean you felt like
you're in your right you know we wrote
these sketches together so Tom didn't
hire you know so what happened is they
go well I will hire Matty Kirsch and
Chris Maguire but this Eddie Bravo guy
has no experience we're gonna hire him
and Joe said wait the [ __ ] you know
you said I can hire anybody I want we're
gonna hire them and they said now we're
not gonna hire that guy so Joe had to
[ __ ] yell at them I got video yeah
video camera because at that point I was
like videotaping everywhere I went
he's on the phone screaming at at people
at Comedy Central you are [ __ ] hire
I'm hiring him and that's all there is
to it you guys [ __ ] lied to me you
guys bullshitting to me you're gonna
[ __ ] iron so he had to go to have a
meeting with them he brought in a VHS
tape with a sketch that I that I did
like at my house I did like some sketch
it's so sad you he has to do this and he
put it in and he goes watch that sketch
this is the guy you're hiring right here
so they watched it and then they said
okay you want to hire this [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] hire cuz Joe gave up like he
was getting yeah good crazy so they
hired me but from day one there were
dicks to me because of that because of
that they just ignored me they said all
your sketches we had all that we had 25
sketches something like that 20 25
sketches ready to go and so we're gonna
use none of them
you got three new ones and they still
have never used them have those sketch
has ever been created and put out two
sketches two sketches but that's it
eventually they ended up using two and
that the sketches that were getting
greenlit all the other writers that took
those nine slots that were all Tom's
guys and then he was green lighting he
had the green light power he was green
lighting all his buddy sketches and
crushing mine and Joe's so I realize
[ __ ] I just quit I quit my DJing job for
this [ __ ] I had ten years DJing at strip
clubs making cash every night so so you
bet so at that point do you get out of
it no I couldn't go back to the strip
club it was over once you quit I
basically tell them I said [ __ ] you guys
I'm gonna Holly I'm a writer own up yeah
we're gonna make movies and I started
you know and I thought you know it was
always about the music so I thought okay
I'll do this comedy then I'll just use
my music in the comedy sketch yeah oh
then we're gonna the comedy show is
gonna blow up and then we're gonna start
making movies like the Wayans brothers
and then I'll I'll slide my music in on
the soundtrack mission accomplished
that's what I thought you know but that
and I think that's a natural way to
think you know well what would happen
we backup is once I started smoking weed
yeah my whole brain changed right away I
understood how to put together stand-up
comedy I got it the weed made me
understand I go I get was just the
formula that you know how to you know
how to set jokes up and and that's when
I started doing stand-up because I like
Joe Joe encouraged me to do it and I
thought I could do it now I could the
weed made me understand stand-up for
some reason and it changed my music I
dropped all the heavy [ __ ] right when I
start smoking I dropped all the heavy
[ __ ] and started playing acoustic and
with with chick singers and started
riding like [ __ ] like Mazzy Star
Times stuff and like Sarah McLaughlin
had a 180 or so i made a 180 yeah but so
so the weed has such an effect but it
sounds like the ability to mast like
i've never did you just change that for
me like I used to smoke weed like I'm
sober unfortunately right it [ __ ]
sucks but for now it sucks but but when
I used to smoke weed I couldn't smoke it
after a while cuz I got too paranoid
yeah because I never looked at it is yet
too much stress in your life yes
smoke weed when shit's going great and
then it'll go it'll go better but it we
doesn't make you feel good or bad that's
fine whatever you want you can make it
feel whatever you want like some people
think oh [ __ ] I'm stressed out I better
smoke weed that's big it works for them
because that's what they believe that
right that's what every want to relax
them weed makes your brain turn the [ __ ]
on so whatever you want to believe you
want if you believe weed makes you
paranoid every time you smoke in you
will be paranoid every time you smoke is
it still we hear let's finish something
Chris Crescent was there a defeat or
something that you really like that
altered the way that you thought felt
about fighting or that adjusted like
your desire to do it was there because I
noticed for me like even as you know in
my life in certain common certain
moments if I've you know been in a been
on a stage and not done well or
something it's definitely maybe left
with a lot of doubt you know did you
have anything like that because it
sounds like you had a couple of
different plates going on you're writing
you got the you know you have the
jujitsu going on it's always about the
music you got these back beats in your
head that you're you know that are
carrying you forward yeah was there a
defeat like in fighting that kind of
well that defeat I was telling you about
leo
he kicked my ass after I shocked the
world and it was biggest upset in
jiu-jitsu history 20 minutes later I get
my house tour in did you feel I felt
like okay that just it was like winning
the Super Bowl and then them coming out
going you got to play another Super Bowl
and then getting killed in that Super
Bowl would you still feel happy
it'd be like I don't know how like I was
doing I was like a little depressed man
do you realize that that's how life is
it's like you can only really get on
such a high if your ego gets too high I
feel like anyway for me every time
there's gonna be something right after
yes that's gonna level you out yeah when
shit's going great I feel I'm like damn
everything is so good someone's gonna
[ __ ] oh I started taking I always feel
holsters I start making sure everybody's
okay I'm like somebody's gonna [ __ ]
Rock yeah I feel that way so what I
learned from that match was I approached
that match with the worse mentality ever
I I lost before the match happened
because before that tournament
um even though beating where the Gracie
was huge I thought at that time the
hardest guy was gonna be Leo Viera
because the the championship before that
he was up a weight class and he went
against my master Jean Jacques Machado
and even though my master Jean Jean
Jacques Machado beat him in a higher
weight class my master didn't tap him
and he [ __ ] me up at will he taps me at
will so I thought damn that guy must be
really good if he survived he still lost
but he survived
and then by the time the next
championship rolled around ADCC
he decided to lose weight and come down
my weight class I'm like oh no this
[ __ ] is gonna be in my weight
class holy [ __ ]
so I was really worried about that guy
yeah I wasn't worried as much about
Hoyer Gracie who was the champ at my
weight division the last three
championships and no one's ever scored a
point against him but because he didn't
look menacing he looked kind of lanky he
didn't look yoked he I felt like [ __ ] I
think I could beat him like I felt a
little hotter this year this year I felt
like I could beat him just because he
was skinny yeah
but Leo Vieira he's like it's super
efficient an acrobat do
backflips like it's nothing I was
worried about don't come in his mouth so
after I upset Hoyle er already right
away I knew who was next and I was
thinking this it's like winning a
million dollars but knowing that you got
to give it all back
you know like [ __ ] how do you feel you
want to know backstage we're going dude
you [ __ ] up you shocked the world I
was like yeah I did didn't I
but I'm thinking about my next match
ready going what do you how you feeling
like it ain't over yet and some guys
about to ruin my party he's about to
[ __ ] my Superbowl champagne pop
collaboration oh that's all I'm thinking
he I wasn't I wasn't that happy cuz I
knew it was all coming to an end and so
so I approached that match thinking that
he was gonna [ __ ] me out I was like
already like there's he's gonna [ __ ] up
my whole party like lightning can strike
twice and when I walked on the match to
face him he was really worried about me
he's in a yoga he's in a yoga stance or
I'm like he's sitting in a yoga position
with this his thumbs together like that
his eyes closed and he's he's doing all
these breathing exercises like on the
side of the mountain here I'm walking
out already thinking that I'm gonna get
killed and his coach is yelling like you
know she was [ __ ] in his ear and
Portuguese I'm sure was probably like
he's just a human you could beat him
you're better than him you know yeah you
got to get yourself confident like coach
and I'm thinking that is so unnecessary
everything you guys are doing you're
gonna [ __ ] me up that's the guy that's
the mentality ahead I already lost ya
and halfway through that match he was
[ __ ] me a pass in my guard and just on
all these points and half and I'm just
like listless and then halfway through
that match I snapped out of it and I
thought wait a minute [ __ ] am i doing I
gotta go after this guy what am i doing
like I'm in a fog over here so it was
too late though I snapped out of it I
wouldn't even if I were to had a winning
attitude he would've still beat me but
not as bad I think so I learned from
that that how important having
confidence is in doing anything whether
it's jiu-jitsu or music and you got to
have confidence yeah otherwise you know
you know not confidence that you're
gonna win a hundred percent but
confidence that you can win and that you
know what you do can
yeah you can't lose too but you got to
know that you can win too if if you know
things go your way and with a little
luck and you know yeah I used to be so
bad at basketball but when I would get
in the games I would be so nervous that
I would completely that would overshadow
any of my skill set or anything it felt
like my hands didn't belong to me
anymore
it just felt bizarre yeah and it was it
had nothing to do with my physical
ability it was all wrapped in confidence
in confidence and stand-ups like that if
you don't have confidence you get on
stage you're gonna eat [ __ ] yeah you
gotta [ __ ] you better fake that
confidence you better get up there and
do it yeah it feels a lot more yeah and
that's one thing that's that's changed
for me in the past year even two years
is just I feel when I get on stage now
like oh I'm excited about putting on
this show for these people whether then
can I put on this show for these people
yeah you know it's not can I anymore
it's I'm excited to have fun yeah I'm
gonna have fun and they're gonna have
fun yeah and this is gonna be a blast
and and I don't even feel like it's
almost less ego now it used to be like I
had this chip on my shoulder sometimes
like imma show these [ __ ] you
know this M&M like [ __ ] all these white
people even though I'm white I'm saying
[ __ ] like that and I would just want to
hammer the jokes into him so hard but it
came from a place a little bit of edge
you know yeah whereas now it comes from
a place like I want them to have fun you
know and I know that that if I take care
of myself and show up and be okay and
ride this confidence that I know it's
gonna work for both of us you know it's
definitely little bit different yeah
your your comedy special is awesome man
oh thanks man
I got I brought up that I was gonna do
your podcast you came up and then Joe
just going on about you know when Joe
cuz we've been on the used to go on the
road with him just to hang out with them
yeah any time we went on the road back
when I was single
either he was on the road and I was with
them or he was you know at the comedy
store you know and he was in town either
way I was always with Joe I've seen his
set thousands of [ __ ] time yeah and
we would break down comedians all the
goddamn time together and for him to say
what he said about you I knew I'm like
oh [ __ ] of Joe is saying that you're on
some whole new level now I go okay cuz
I'm always looking for a good stand-up I
was like Netflix there's all these
Netflix specials but you know
90% of them or week so I'm always
looking for the good ones like Michael
chase Michael chain matters he crushed
she's like I gotta check it out he's on
I saw Mike Epps when do you see Mike
Epps I thought Mike set Epps was good
they hated on it on rum I have to see
that new one no no this has been out
probably about two years that's that's
not yes not too old but uh but Thank You
Man I appreciate yours was awesome thank
you [ __ ] entertaining his [ __ ] always
been obsessed with comedy and I still am
I'm always looking for you know
recommendations like who's good do you
think you're a guy because you go from
genre you know you don't go from genre
to genre but it seems like you get
excited about something and you you know
I mean I noticed this about Joe he has
Joe is always enthusiastic about almost
anything like he's just generally
excited about life you know Rogan and
that's like just like it's a gift that
he has yeah you know like you start
talking about some of these Jenny's
interested he wants to know he wants to
you know he has this passion that just
is its alertness he's there he wants to
you know he wants to achieve you know do
you feel like because you kind of go
from Jean you know you're in different
genres you know it's like I mean to be
able to kind of master the physical
world of fighting and then you know to
be able to like contemplate music and
and make it work for you find a way that
it makes makes it work for you
you know and then it's to be writing to
you like I'm just curious as to what do
you find that do you think that you're
like a chameleon or do you think that
you're somebody who's who once you find
something it seems like you find
something you make it fit for you that's
you know like people even say some of
your coaching methods and stuff for like
kind of unique in their own world deef
that's a good question um all I could
say is my whole life I was been obsessed
with fighting music and comedy those
three things I've always been obsessed
with always since I saw I remember the
first time I saw Eddie Murphy delirious
I was 13 my brother was 17 and he had a
15 year old girlfriend so she had a
laserdisc player
and we heard about this Eddie Murphy guy
so my brother said dude my girlfriend's
mom's taking off come over at like 7:00
or whatever we'll watch them you your
brother and his girlfriend yes yeah
she's 15 and he's 17 and I'm like 13 so
we're watching delirious on laserdisc
dying and I don't know her we turn to
the Sun and her mom was standing right
there I'll never forget her mom just
standing there while we're watching and
she's looking she's looking at anymore
he's tall mikuni google dis and
goonie-goo-goo-foofie this [ __ ] she
takes off for a half an hour she comes
back she busts us watching some dirty
ass [ __ ] yeah and she just stood there
for a couple minutes just loving just
and we're like trying to hold it and
we're holding we just can't because if
you laughing you're enjoying it even
worse so she just turns around and walks
away and goes upstairs to her room and
she let us watch the rest of it so I'm
never do you think she thought she
thought this is okay or that I'm gonna
just let him have this one yeah I don't
know I didn't know her that well yeah I
remember exactly what she looks I'll
never forget that face the way the TV
light hit her face and like she just
looks so angry but didn't say [ __ ] she
just walked away and we just watched the
rest of it dude I remember making love
to this girl one time or not even making
love but trying to and and her mom came
home right this is and this is like the
first time I was ever like just started
having sex you know when I was young and
her mom came home open the door and
we're in her bed right and I had to go
and I was just like you know I'm always
pretty affable with parents on us walked
over and just [ __ ] introduced myself
busted when I was 14 my girlfriend at
the time we're having sex and her dad
came home and I just jumped in the
closet naked with a condom on and just
hiding in the closet shaking waiting for
him to leave and he took so long for him
to leave by the time he loved it I
passed out in the closet and my dick was
like super small and it still had the
condom just like barely hanging off
that's all that was that was one of the
funnest things I liked about being young
was sneaking around and [ __ ] or like
I used to steal kids bikes I would leave
their like I would ride like a little
girl's bike over to like this girlfriend
I was dating her house was like four
miles away and I would sneak in in the
middle of the night and she had these
loud cats that had to sleep in a room
like her parents made all the cats stay
in her bedroom at night with her right
so I'd be in there try to like go down
on there be like nine cats [ __ ]
jumping on my back and [ __ ] licking
my feet and stuff dude it was a way if I
can create the first time I had sex is a
crazy story where I was going out I
started dating this girl I was we were
both in seventh grade we're both 13 and
we'd start off making out you know for
three hours and I go yeah forever and
then you try to get in the back of her
shirt in the small of her back then she
pushes the hand away on your vaak then
two weeks later you you try to get in
that small in the back and then she
pushes it away then she finds the
finally lets you make out with her and
you're touching the small in the back
then you go higher on the back for two
weeks
you try to reach over to the tits
machine she had like little mosquito
bites but she had a bra and it drives I
tried to get in there you know I try to
get in there boom and then she pushed
the hand away and then two weeks later I
try it again she pushed the handle away
and finally she said [ __ ] it I I made my
way over to the tits and she took her
bra down grab my hand and put it right
on that nipple and she put her right on
that titty that freaked me the phone
yeah oh [ __ ] and then from that point on
little by little
it took about ten months you know we
were dry humping once we got the dry
humping and we're both nutty we were dry
humping and we would both night I said
why should you or not I was we were done
we were just grinding we just thought
yeah winding on each other just grind
it's like she would come I would come
you know and we were good and at that
point I was done I'd never progressed
after that and so that's as far as you
and her god yeah at that that at that
point and then her sister who is a year
younger than her was already having sex
with her boyfriend so they had a talk
and and her sister gave her some advice
chuckles because she was she was
thinking like why isn't he going further
it's time we we went all the way dan and
I wasn't going all the way I was done I
would nut in my underwear I'd go home
take my underwear off throw them in the
hamper and just watch some TV yes
I didn't need to go any further did you
feel do you feel like almost like
thankful that you weren't going further
in a way because you didn't want to be
having sex yeah I didn't know what the
post nut syndrome was just knew that I
would I would do it we would grind and
they were great and then when I came I
didn't want to do it no yeah I didn't I
didn't understand post nuts syndrome
yeah I just thought okay we don't need
to go further I don't even want to go
further I don't the last thing I want to
do is do more yeah I want to go home
morning at home that was yeah I didn't
get it only a car daddy son I always
knew that when you masturbated when I
masturbated when I was when I was done I
does the last thing I wanted to do I
always thought that was weird I thought
it wouldn't it be great I remember
telling my friends wouldn't be great if
you played with yourself and you never
got tired you could just keep going I
was thought like the orgasm was oh I got
tired and now I'm exhausted now I don't
want to do it no more because I'm too
tired I didn't get what was going on
biologically right but then she my
girlfriend finally said I think I I
think you should get a condom mm-hmm
what yeah so I'm 13 years old where the
[ __ ] am I gonna get a condom because I
think it's time we took it we took the
next step and went all the way and I
thought [ __ ] and I had told all my
brother and all my friends that I was
with that I wasn't a virgin cuz you
don't want to be you want to say I did
have sex once when I was 12 it was a
soon yeah I'm at a damn she was an you
know in the next city oh yes always
meanwhile I just made out with her it
behind a bush yeah but I told everybody
that I had sex but nobody believed my
brother was four years old and me
already having lots of sex and he knew I
was bullshitting does your [ __ ] lying
I can sit here I know I did I'm not a
virgin because you're [ __ ] burn a lot
of virgin so I was just lying so anyways
so now back to my my girlfriend see you
girls ready she said get the condom so I
had it so I was a fee to get her nose
done Dorothy I remember the but I took
the aquabox of Trojans 36 I went into I
went into what was it was thrifty drugs
that I remember in the Rite Aid yeah
turned into had ice cream over there yes
exactly they turned into Rite Aid so
back when I was thrifty I would I would
always steal stuff I was a little thief
poor Mexican just stealing [ __ ] oh yeah
picking stuff up borrowing it yeah I
used yeah I would steal our NFL pencils
and sell them at school for 10 cents
like yeah there's a pencil hustlin yeah
but anyways so I went in bought a box of
36 condoms putting it up my electric
blue
ski jacket ripped them off finally it's
time to have a set have sex now I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
so her parents were constantly in and
out that odd jobs her mom was a hair
stylist so she was like I had an
irregular schedule and her dad was like
unemployed half the time so we always
had a look out the window when we're
making out we always had a keep lookout
always it would make out in the in the
garage so cuz we could hear the car
coming them then we we'd go into the
living room by the time they open that
front door we're watching MTV yeah every
time oh hi you know so we had all that
[ __ ] planned out so it's time to have
sex we go into a room and the window in
the room you know that you could see the
front yard so I'm like oh [ __ ] she get
she's just naked under the covers like
undercover that's nice that's romantic I
get on top put the condom on took
forever put the condom on I didn't know
where the hole was so I thought the hole
was up at the very top the top boom boom
I'm like trying to poke her right at the
top and I think it's a common problem
Virgin sap so as I was poking she's like
she's like no that's not it I'm like
[ __ ] is that it and then I came yeah and
I didn't tell her I came trying to find
the hole so I owe my god your dad's here
just oh [ __ ] she had a long dress on so
she could just stand up and she's got a
dress on so I ran out to the living room
and I you know I got dressed randomly
and then she comes out she goes no false
alarm
nobody's here well who [ __ ] somebody
in a long dress well it was the plan
like if someone came home she stand up
that's a good policies gun officer got
to do stand-up so she comes in women's
like if false alarm
my dad's not here and I said you know
what I got a bad feeling about this
let's just wait like 45 minutes I go I
got a bad feeling I didn't tell her I'm
not it right you know what I mean so we
wagers and why do we wake up let's just
wait so I was too embarrassed each other
I was done all right
so waiting like 45 minutes and I'm gonna
try again and boom I I just couldn't
find the whole side told her you gotta
help me so she grabbed grab my dick and
she put it all in its uh she put her I
had no idea took you to that door I had
no idea the [ __ ] hole was right next to
the [ __ ] yeah I'll try to hide it
I was way off I would have never figured
that [ __ ] up yeah on my wall I was way
off so I put it in maybe three or four
strokes ya know what I'm done and I was
just so [ __ ] I thought maybe
something's wrong with her I'm like
maybe her [ __ ] holes by the [ __ ] but
it's not maybe she had like a defective
[ __ ] so I go home and I told my tell my
brother guess what nicole has Kristi
hole next to her [ __ ] and he said
they're all by the ass you [ __ ] lied
oh no that's that's how I got busted
dude I dated a girl who her [ __ ] was at
her cooter was up front
oh [ __ ] really very front for not
nowhere near the [ __ ]
no no oh yeah but like a front-end
loader that's that's what I thought
that's very rare a beautiful girl and
you wouldn't think it but she had that
cooter up front and then I dude I
remember one time this girl when I first
started dating a girl when I first like
a you know sprayed out around a young
lady it was this girl jerked me off of
this boat dock into this river and it's
like it's just kind of not a river but
like a little pond or whatever and a
bunch of fish came up and ate the semen
oh so if he [ __ ] blew my mind dude
and I would have dreams that there was
like mmm gonna be sharks out in the
ocean that looked like me and she and I
was gonna trip and I was like holy [ __ ]
man because everything had just happened
I just came this girl was right there
the first time somebody had seen me come
and then these fish came up and it
almost seemed like they were like
stealing I don't know man it seemed like
they were like he's trying to steal my
thunder or something
but anyhow man yeah dude I miss being
young because everything was new and it
was like adventurous you know and he but
you seem like the kind of guy that
always like creates or finds something
in your life that makes things kind of
new or makes things novel and I know a
lot of people now talk to you about you
know you're like become like the
conspiracy theorist guy you know you've
become like the you know or the guy that
like a lot of people like to go in on
about like oh you know Eddie has these
crazy ideas are these wild beliefs do
you think that you always were like a
questioner of things or do you think
that you gravitate towards like whatever
is just the next biggest curiosity for
you
well when I was a kid I was hardcore
Catholic I was uh you know my step that
was dig my real dad was never around my
mom was working all day so yeah that's
good it's a lot of I try to kill myself
when I was eight I try to overdose on a
bottle of Thera grin and those about
vitamins remember that with a good day
one today I thought I was eight I just
went to sleep woke up my damn I'm still
alive but but um I mean that's sad but I
mean I feel you it sad sad but it's
Chris yeah my stepdad was evil that's a
wild choice yeah he was evil I just had
a dream about him the other day like I
was gonna [ __ ] him up in my dream like I
was in his front yard hmm and I could
see him looking out his window and I'm
just like warm I think I'll [ __ ] him up
like I just wanted to [ __ ] him up he's
still in my brain I haven't seen him
since you know I haven't he I haven't
lived at them since I was 10 but um did
you you've ever had a dream we try to
punch somebody and you can't in your fit
your fist slows down in the air how
about you shoot a gun and the bullet
comes out yeah emotion you know I'm like
I'm trying to kill a [ __ ] my
dream but what is that was a part why do
you think it's hard to harm people in
your subconscious I feel like I think
that when you're asleep you're not sharp
you know you're just lazy so you're just
exception most of the time when I dream
I always I never really never realized
that I make money teaching jiu-jitsu and
I have plenty of money right I don't
need money my money is fine for me but
in my dream um broke and I just lost my
job
and I don't know how I'm gonna pay rent
and that happens a lot so I think you
just you're asleep and you're just not
thinking properly I think that that's it
like my DJing at a strip club was a
super fun job it was it was awesome I
know it sounds good I think it's every
guy's dream job a little but to be a DJ
at a strip club you have to be sharp in
the sense that you have to know what
every girl likes you have to have a set
ready to go like if this if Candy's
gonna go up next but you have to skip
her now BQ ever sets picked out you got
a skipper now because she got a lap
dance and you you have 15 seconds to
find another girl you need to find that
girl on the right music for you rather
you got to be really short Himalaya
coming up yeah
got Himalaya coming to the stage so you
got to be sharp with the CDs you know
and that the songs and the girls you got
to know their name
yeah so when I dream about working at
the strip club the dreams I think are
supposed to be awesome dreams but
because I don't remember any of the
songs and I can't make out any of the
girls I'm just it's [ __ ] a nightmare
I'm just like the managers are looking
at me I'm [ __ ] up the sets without I
can't even I can't even read the seed
everybody listening Nellie yes sorry Z
so because of the nature of the job I
think I think when I dream it turns into
a nightmare but it's not supposed to be
a nightmare like if I was the strip club
manager they don't have they're not on a
clock they don't have to put a new song
in every two minutes 45 seconds you got
to be a machine you can [ __ ] around no
matter what's going on you better have a
new song at 2:45 you better not let it
go 3:30 we're wasting mine right that's
money we gotta start the next dance a
new money new money new money so it's
really stressful but as a manager you
just kick back and not think about [ __ ]
if I was a manager I think my dreams of
the strip club would be less stressful
and I would be it'd be like yeah but I
don't know why so we starts on my drums
do you think this snow is interesting
because I was talking about you know if
I've tried to punch people and dreams oh
yes and and my fists
get so hard it's slow and heavy and it
won't ever I can never hit the person
yeah that's that's normal Tony we're
talking about my string about my step
down in my step that was a dick yeah
was before that I was talking about like
do you feel like um you know just to get
into conspiracies
Oh a little bit in acoustic you kind of
become a little bit like the conspiracy
yeah well that seems like people just
want to kind of attack you about you
know they want they want to attack me
for not trusting criminals can you
believe that right yeah well they don't
want to think with you sometimes they
want people people attack me because I
don't trust criminals yeah that's why
they attacked me I don't trust any
information coming from a goddamn
criminal yeah and if you look at
everybody will agree that the government
is corrupt yes everybody a hundred
percent of everybody will agree
that the government is corrupt yes and
they there they're involved in criminal
activities right yet yet like you know
and the government's are definitely
involved in like people have died
because of the corruption in government
right everybody agreement is so much
proof like how do you Bay of Pigs
everything there's so so much proof
operation Northwoods even even like
people that like always defend the
government they will acknowledge that
operation Northwoods was real where they
were planning on so when you look at the
government the government is if you if
you narrow down the government to one
person it would be like would you agree
to be like the government's kind of like
arturo got arturo gatti john gotti right
like a gangster yeah you know what I
mean right right so so for me it's very
similar right
so you just I'm trying to simplify it
hmm if you just look at like I don't
trust anything coming from John Gotti
yeah he's murdered [ __ ] he's a
he's a shady gangster that's that's how
I perceived the government to be so
anytime I get information from the
government a government agency whether
it's NASA or whatever you know NASA
faked six moon missions man I mean how
are you gonna believe anything from them
did I met muzzle how you gonna believe
anything from them
I met Buzz Aldrin and he seemed no joke
he seemed like he hadn't [ __ ] him into
the moon man of course he hasn't you
know cuz I'm trying to like engage him
and this will look and his eyes seemed
so like yeah like he was trying to just
play a little bit of a part so I don't
believe anything care from yeah I've
never trusted the government of anything
anything you know then they say well
what about space I go all our space
information since 1958 that's when the
NASA was formed in 1958 all our info and
there it was formed by Nazis Wernher von
Braun the director of all six fake moon
missions was one of Hitler's right-hand
men he was a [ __ ] rocket scientist
for Hitler who was evil as [ __ ] he
directed six moon missions masters of
propaganda guy he'd be the perfect guy
to do that and and when he died he was
like he was on some deathbed
confessional type [ __ ] he told his
assistant he said on his deathbed
according to her
said the fake alien invasion is coming
hmm like the fake alien invasion is what
they've been planning
that's what's gonna scare everybody into
a one-world government
it's always been about a one-world
government and the fake alien invasion
that'll get everybody together everybody
will volunteer so we got us you know the
aliens are gonna kill us we got all
unite you know that's been the plan the
fake and that's what Wernher von Braun
sent and on his tombstone on his
tombstone it has a psalm whatever like
Psalm 8 I don't know like the Bible
verses verses but it's a particular
Psalm in the Bible mm-hmm it talks about
the firmament which is that what what
people believe that like around go
around there's a dome firmament we're in
an enclosed system we're in a special
place
why the [ __ ] would he have that on his
tombstone but it doesn't prove anything
right there's no proof they have all
that they have all the information NASA
so when they're when they're telling us
that the Sun is 93 million miles away
and when the that's what they say yeah
like 93 million miles away the stomach's
93 [ __ ] million miles away it doesn't
look that far away no it doesn't look up
a line it's interesting you say that -
because I mean at the beginning of the
year the White House was releasing that
alien footage
remember we even played pushing it
they're pushing all that they're pushing
part of it I used to be a super fan of
aliens in space I would I would I still
I threw all the DVDs away but I had
stacks and stacks me and Joe we'd watch
space documentaries all the [ __ ] time
over and over and over BBC's space that
right yeah over and over all the space
documentaries you could find I would
[ __ ] videotape that [ __ ] I was a
space junkie and every now and then
every now and and I wonder it is kind of
weird that a hundred percent of these
space documentaries are all CGI cartoons
none of its footage from actual like
satellites or or anything like that I
thought that was kind of weird but I'm
like oh they got it all figured out and
then I continue to watch it I continue
to watch it and then once I the first
distrust of the world was when I found
out everybody wasn't Catholic because I
grew up in a Catholic neighborhood
everybody was kin
yeah everybody then once I realized and
I was a altar boy trying to get the [ __ ]
in heaven I go I'm going to heaven oh
yeah
altar boy [ __ ] going to church I'm
going to heaven [ __ ] oh yeah a first
round trial then when I found out dude I
would have been totally first round I
was I could see that lay horse round I'm
going to have that was version
[ __ ] this life then once I realized that
not everybody's Catholic or the words a
Jew what's a Muslim
what's Hindu my wait a minute there's
hundred there's millions of people that
aren't Catholic out there then what's
gonna happen to them what happen
although how are we right how do we know
we're right again so right away I'm like
right away I became an atheist I get 12
and 13 11 12 13 I'm like [ __ ] there's no
God this is all [ __ ] okay well that
was the first my first taste of you
can't trust Authority my second taste
was at 15 at 15 I'm balls deep into
Slayer balls deep and uh bad speed metal
bands that write satanic lyrics I didn't
believe they were satanic I don't
believe they were satanic at all
I just believe oh we're just trying to
scare people I'm writing satanic lairs
weird you trying to scares people I
don't even believe in God I'm a
Halloween exactly it's like dudes who
are into writing movies like The
Exorcist you don't think the director of
the extras is the tank you just think
the writing scary [ __ ] I love this [ __ ]
that's I never looked at Slayer I'm 15
I'm like those [ __ ] are in
satanic they're just writing scary [ __ ]
and it's cool upside-down cross cool but
then in 2020 was a show back in the
least oh yeah I remember 2020 everybody
watched 2020 back before the internet
they did a special on satanic music and
it was all about like old ladies telling
you know saying that you know if you're
if your kids are listening the Twisted
Sister and Motley and they dare
hellbound and I was thinking dude you
got the wrong [ __ ] bands it's not
Twisted Sister that's not satanic Dee
Snider you got to get into Bathory and
creator and destruction real they were
mentioning any of it like a c4 what
about acid bath you ever heard of them
no no they were bringing up like Judas
Priest and [ __ ] like there so at that
point I thought wow these [ __ ]
don't know [ __ ] on this is an ABC yeah
they should have been talking about
Slayer then I would have understood I'll
be like yeah yeah yeah because every
songs about Satan yeah yeah but they
didn't talk about that [ __ ] they were
talking about like [ __ ] Motley Crue
what do you then realize just what how
out of touch they are or how much
they're trying to control
how just how they're put in there can't
trust you can't trust the mainstream I
was already not trusting them the speed
metal band I was in was called
resistance and it was all about not
trusting the government okay well then
how about this so say if say if like you
know the world that we live in now you
know people talk about you know like the
earth is round or that you know or
they're with this flat or that we're
living in side of somebody else's
creation like what why would like why
would they say something more powerful
than us is created this world or
controls us that we're living in a
controlled environment why would they
let us start to think this is what I
wonder sometimes why do they let us
start to realize it there there's a or
do you think there's an image in the
system no there's a big movement trying
to stomp out like Flat Earth theory like
um like any conspiracy theory that is
out there to say like 9/11 right 9/11
for sure was an inside job there's no
doubt if you look into it it's no doubt
no doubt there's an inside [ __ ] job if
you actually look into it right so
there's um there's a people being paid
to put together debunk videos for 9/11
there's websites being made there's a
like documentaries put on like Nat Geo
and [ __ ] to debunk 9/11 inside was a
inside job o to debunked it was inside
job yeah okay the people who were
responsible for it those same people are
putting out the information so when you
when you go to YouTube for instance you
punch a 911 inside job you're not gonna
get any of the really real videos they
got the search engines control yes mark
yeah so that all the videos that come up
are gonna be like if people are
interested in 9/11 they're gonna go
actually this is they're gonna go that's
not real because the real [ __ ] won't
come up for a long time yeah so they got
the search engines controlled right
that's right yeah easy to do easy to do
yes so any any conspiracy theories same
thing you like JFK even for Jeff get go
to YouTube go JFK a conspiracy yeah and
you ain't gonna get no real [ __ ] not
that all the [ __ ] the debunking [ __ ]
comes up first right right same thing
well then and wouldn't it be smart too
wouldn't it be smart for the people that
like for 9/11 for instance to the start
a website what it said
9/11 inside job truth dot-com own that
[ __ ] hmm
start talking about sending people there
but meanwhile they're gonna it's a
debunker side right way good idea that's
what they do that's what they do but I
don't even have a documentary on on
cable that says 9/11 was it an inside
job most people think or a lot of people
are now thinking that it's an inside job
tonight at 11:00 we're gonna investigate
it so it appears to be investigator yeah
that's our ed up but it's not it's not
they get you and then they do the
narrator's to those documentaries are
there just like Kondos say okay you know
real scientists believe this but the
conspiracy theorists they believe this
it's ridiculous yeah why is it that
people who always think outside of the
box these days are considered like such
alter you know like it's just so looked
down upon like even Kanye the other day
was talking about like just different
ways of of talking about slavery or just
different months and he's just even
speaking on it right and sure Kanye's
all over the place but it's like if
somebody even brings up an idea
sometimes immediately it's just short
like people are dumb as [ __ ] now people
are dumbest even to think like no ties
yeah what's okay with it like sir
somebody says hey think about it this
way and people are like no [ __ ] you but
they're not saying that that's the truth
they're saying hey just think did
there's a bunch there's a video with a
bunch of black celebrities like Ice Cube
50 sad Shaquille O'Neal there's like
five or six of them going to trump
school man Trump's way cool oh yeah and
racist we did we hang out with them that
guy says he's a boss yeah but what Kanye
says it says it then they attack him
they Lynch him vanya is so influential
you can let 50 cent say what I want
start stalking different yeah people
people are hypnotized that's what's
going on people there's mass hypnosis
going on oh I'm a victim of Allah so I
can feel it I can feel myself starting
to escape from it sometimes but do you
why do why are we allowed to as as
humans as thinkers in whatever world
this is and whenever we're living in why
does say it's controlled by some things
why does that thing allow us to start to
question they're not allowing us to
question we're questioning we're waking
up on our own and they're doing
everything to stomp it out like Flat
Earth you go Flat Earth you go to
YouTube you're gonna get nothing but the
bunker videos like right why are they
making videos debunking Flat Earth if
it's so stupid why are there people
making videos and spending a lot of time
full-time jobs
debunking what what we live on yeah why
are they doing how does Flat Earth have
such legs how does it have legs it's so
dumb right how is it how is it just it
just keeps growing and growing people
are waking the [ __ ] up and what are they
scared of that we're gonna break you
later you can't you can't the the Jesuit
goal is a one world order moving one
world good all the secret society skull
and bones there's a bunch of Freemasons
there's a bunch of yeah secret societies
that all work together they want a
one-world government and the way it's
gonna happen is from a fake alien
invasion they're already preparing for
it they're doing arenas Project Blue
Beam that's what they're doing so I used
to be ruling in aliens big time then I
realize oh [ __ ] they're tricking
everybody there they're making it so the
alien community they're gone look
there's all these government programs
project Bluebook
they're all there their height they got
all these documents were there
investigating UFOs the government really
knows that [ __ ] is all done on purpose
so it looks like the government's hiding
it it looks like rice so it makes you
believe it but meanwhile they're not
hiding it they created it they created a
Roswell all that shit's fake that's all
fake I used to believe that I used to
believe all that I should crash UFOs and
on [ __ ] that [ __ ] ain't real they want
you to believe that the government is
trying to hide it that's brilliant
yes so now I look at that now I look at
all the UFO sightings like that's
government [ __ ] right yes they know that
we're looking for it so now they're
putting it out there so that they can
sell rolls
so once the fake alien invasion happens
everybody buys it hook line and sinker
we go one-world government and you can't
go why are they lying to us about space
you can't have a fake alien invasion
without space yeah right you have to
have from somewhere who hears something
gets you know they have to come from
this infinite space and when you
look at what um you know people always
talk about you know even Joe Rogan like
man like like the conspiracy theory is
that a long time ago we still be really
really smart we figured out a bunch of
[ __ ] thirty thousand years ago a hundred
thousand years ago and then something
happened civilization fell apart then we
had to start over again right when
mainstream science will tell us that you
know dinosaurs
cavemen and then slowly we got to the
point we're at here and we're at the
pinnacle of technology technology has
never been as high as it is right now
that's what the mainstream storyline is
but the conspiracy theory there's one of
the conspiracy theories is like they
used to be people used to be really
smart look at the pyramids we still
can't even make a pyramid now all these
people are willing to believe that
people used to be sway smarter than we
are now right if that's true then they
would know what we live on but you know
they would have a better idea than we do
right and so back then like all the
ancient cultures they all believed we
live that Hindus everybody they all
believed we live in an enclosed
structure like this is a special place
and there's a firmament it's it's in the
Bible and people you can you know the
Bible don't should the Bible ain't real
but you know what I'm not a like a
devout Christian I'm not a bible thumper
hmm but I do believe that there's
probably some real [ __ ] if there's some
clues in there there's some real [ __ ] in
do you think but why are we alike if we
start do you worry that if we start to
get alert to things and people start to
become aware that we're gonna be
something's gonna happen to us like as
individuals that start to become aware
like do you ever worry about that like
the more awake that you get to what's
really going on that because obviously
then we're a hindrance to whatever the
overall plan is for sure everyone you
know everyone's susceptible to getting
suicided if you have a big enough mouth
for sure do you feel like that could be
I mean did you know I'm so small time
and I'm so crazy are you though I'm
talking my Flat Earth and stop time
yeah I'm not I'm
so off the radar you know what I mean
I'm not I'm not we did it we did a
podcast for about an hour we didn't talk
about conspiracy theories
I turned down can I've been approached
to different now three three different
production companies want me to be a
host for some conspiracy theory show
like [ __ ] that I don't want to be no
conspiracy theory ghost because you
think something could be you but do you
think like cuz I'm thinking if I'm
running around and that's part of you
know the vibe that I'm carrying with me
yeah then somebody who has a bigger
ability to me and more control could
would shut me down like a row maybe that
could happen that could happen but I'm
already shutting myself down right I'm
not doing conspiracy theory shows I'm
only talking of my conspiracy theories
on podcasts where with the host wants to
talk about it
you know I'm it's fascinating yeah you
know it's just it really just comes down
to I don't trust criminals I don't trust
them so when people are [ __ ] making
fun of me and calling me an idiot for
not trusting I don't trust any science
that I can't verify for myself yeah
unless they're gonna throw me in jail if
I don't trust that some science that any
science that we can't verify for
ourselves we got to take someone else's
like some unknown scientist work for
like just the simple fact that that son
is supposedly 93 million miles away me
and you have no way to verify we have
know people will say dude they figured
that out look like a googly so what do
you write that down wrote that down
that's not proof to me and now they're
gonna throw me in jail for not believing
it then I would say I'll believe it you
know what I mean then they would have
the right to call me an idiot
yeah you know what people like you
[ __ ] idiot you don't believe that the
sun's 93 million miles away it says
right there they figured out NASA you
[ __ ] idiot you're a [ __ ] idiot now
they they would have the right to say
that if I was gonna get thrown in jail
right or or if they you know if you
believe that and you sign something that
you believe that they gave you like a
[ __ ] ten thousand dollar tax check or
something like that income tax then they
would go you [ __ ] idiot yeah that's
ten thousand do you're a [ __ ] idiot
but there is no money and there is no
jail so it doesn't benefit me to believe
that the Sun is not Savannah may be it
may be may be but they will hide about
so much [ __ ]
man I don't know constantly and it's
just untrustworthy I mean even how like
you know some of these like you know
you'll have Bernie Sanders who would
have won his political party and then he
gets the land you know he gets it's it's
just it's almost feels so much like how
it's so obvious now yeah yeah we
shouldn't be trusting these powers that
are around us and what gets me about
space is that well my favorite thing
about space is that oh they say spaces
in constantly multiplying infinitely
multiplying how do they know this any
fun that sounds like I would have made
up science that we can't verify for yes
and that's most of like space that's
scientism it may or may not be real but
you gotta have faith you gotta have yeah
you gotta just oh yeah so anytime you
you think you know like you take a
physics class you got an A in physics
and you think you know you know that's
verifying that everything they're saying
about space is real you know ii mean
like that but you're saying that
verifies it yeah ridiculous hypnotize
what's crazy if i told you hey space it
just keeps on growing yeah like that's
uh I mean do you um do you think that
we're shooting through space at a
million miles an hour
no does it feel like we're going a
million miles an hour and it's not just
a million according to mainstream
astrophysics we're going miles an hour
on earth we're spending a thousand miles
an hour on our own access and then we're
shooting around the Sun 60,000 miles an
hour 60,000 and then the Sun is shooting
around the center of the Milky Way at
600,000 miles an hour and the Milky Way
galaxy itself is shooting through the
universe at 1 million that's what they
wrote 1 million watts so we're going
forward can you imagine going a million
miles an hour this way but then you're
skidding this way 600,000 miles and then
skidding another way 60,000 miles an
hour and then oh and you're spinning a
thousand miles an hour that would make
any eight-year-old try to audiometer day
but it was never proven I they never
proved ever there's never been any proof
that we're moving will not proof that we
can conceptualize and that's why I don't
understand why people so easily believe
everything they believe it right now you
know what you know what's interesting
too is that like if you question it for
a second you'll get attacked but if you
believe these
people they've been wrong so many times
throughout history like they used to
think that the Sun revolved around the
earth right these are the same
scientists that are saying all these
things yeah and all of a sudden now the
scientists are never wrong and we had a
choice believe them and never question
because NASA's got some instruments to
measure all that [ __ ] you just got to
believe us right you know what I mean
think about how what is the percentage
of the population worldwide have access
to the high-powered telescopes that
these people in NASA are supposedly
getting all their calculations from now
so less than 1% probably point zero zero
one percent of the population has access
to verify all these findings in space
they found seven every six months they
find seven new pop galaxies yeah come on
man come on man how you show me other
[ __ ] you figure that oh we can figure
out what the light and then there's like
a little light and if you you could go
on YouTube and see what what stars and
planets look like through telescope you
could see that and dude there it looks
like the weirdest lights ever dude and
weirdest [ __ ] it doesn't look like the
CGI that that they're giving us they
give rise some some beautiful plant it's
not it doesn't look it doesn't look at
all like that when you look when you see
it yourself you're not seeing the cgi
paintings and the earthiness of these
[ __ ] nebulas and these star nurseries
that's all to me to me I don't buy any
of that [ __ ] well it's also like um what
gets me is um
that they'll have yeah that so few of us
can really even read this data or any of
that stuff and actually conceptualize it
in a way that scientists yes you gotta
have faith in it you know it's not like
I don't believe in science and I've said
this many times I believe the science of
the iPhone I believe the science in the
iPhone can connect to the internet yeah
I didn't need to read that anywhere I
didn't mean to read a book right because
I can see that you use it I don't know
it I believe in the science of cars yeah
not because I read it anywhere but
because I'm in my goddamn car every day
I know it goes from point A to B I
believe in that science science that I
could verify
science that I can't verify you know but
now if it could say I had some rare form
of cancer right and someone said aid
there's this new treatment there's a
there's a chance that it could cure you
in that situation man I want to trust
that science and let's go for it I want
to trust that science I don't know
what's gonna work but [ __ ] that hope so
I'll give it it is
I trust that science right um I trust
the science of you know surgery because
they're science involved in surgery
there's science involved in surgery like
I've had sir had back surgery and had
knee surgery I believe in that [ __ ]
you know I when when you're talking
about nine planets ten light-years away
that you can't see that no one can see
that we gotta take your word for it that
sounds like a that sounds like a scam
that sounds like you get 18 billion
dollars a year and you gotta have
something to show for it so oh yeah
we're looking for plant we found new
planets oh [ __ ] we're gonna we're going
to Mars okay and and and then when you
look at the that SpaceX stuff it's like
Jesus Christ man you but you believe
have you seen the footage of that Tesla
yeah the space man that's so [ __ ] that
looks so fake even Elon Musk the first
thing that came out of his mouth in the
press conference when they launched that
[ __ ] and the internet revolted said
that's [ __ ] faker than anything I
thought it was gonna look more real I
thought Elon must want a better
technology yeah but they asked him in
the press conference the very first
thing he said they said Elon how does it
feel to finally get your Tesla up in
orbit and enjoy it and how long do you
think we're gonna have contact with it
and the very first thing he said well I
think it's ridiculous and impossible and
you can tell it's real because it looks
so fake that was the first thing that
came out of his [ __ ] mind you can
tell it's real because it looks so fake
if we would he faked it we would use way
better CGI yeah that's the first thing
out of your goddamn mouth yeah that's
the first thing out of your goddamn
mouth and where is that Tesla now
where's it at where's that they faked
every you know how it one way you know
what's fake is that you know when you
turn on your iphone you always get the
CNN and the Washington Post you get all
the fake news writer you subscribe to
that and I get all this you get all that
[ __ ] they force-feed you the fake [ __ ]
yeah right so if you're reading fake
[ __ ] on CNN everyday facia and then on
CNN sa there's
space X launch was successful or
whatever it's [ __ ]
whatever it is that's great the same
thing their whole vibe why would that
story yes
most people don't trust C in it most
people don't agree but they do when they
talk about space yeah it's the same well
what I wonder is what why is space
always so unattainable to us like if we
live it like that's the thing everything
we learn about it is that oh we can't
get there you know like yeah well we
just got to our moon we just reach there
but you know this other thing oh we got
out there just pictures you know how
about this how about this everybody
whether you believe we went to the moon
or not everybody believes that there's a
debate about it right yeah there's
people that believe we went and there's
people believe that it's fake right so
everyone should believe that there's a
debate about it now if you really have
an open mind and you want to get to the
bottom of it say okay government always
lies maybe lad about this let's let's
have an open mind let's get to the
bottom of it and let's let's take it to
trial what's the first thing you're
gonna you're gonna ask for in the trial
to look at all the evidence right now
would be awesome yeah wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be the first thing is okay
first thing we got to do is examine the
evidence right right but you're the
prosecutor no we need to examine the
evidence and the defendant the
government says we destroyed all the
evidence what do you think right at that
point what are you thinking yes what
we're done of course the average person
that isn't hypnotized right with some
decent common sense think at that point
you're on trial go okay let's let's
examine the evidence again when the
defense attorney said rob your honor we
destroyed all the evidence so what is
have taken guilty already guilty I
destroyed the evidence why would you
destroy all that precious evidence of
the greatest achievement of mankind you
destroyed a setting Don Pettit a NASA
astronaut said on a video you watch it
there's a million videos of him copies
of him saying I would go back to the
moon in a nanosecond except them we
don't have the technology to do that
anymore we destroyed that technology and
it's been a painful process to put it
back together that's word for what I got
that [ __ ] memorize
that's crazy and we destroyed the
technology to meet anybody and that's a
crumble they're already criminals right
it's been already criminals right so
automatically you think okay we got
these [ __ ] right oh we got this
[ __ ]
they don't have off as that as a board
yeah we're like these guys are [ __ ]
they destroy the evidence okay it's on
now yeah it would be an open-and-shut
case at that point is if we tried that
argument we're in jail and we can get
speedy exit exam I'm gonna give up Zach
20 years and exactly exactly you know
the whole thing about space here's
there's there's so many ways you can
break down space and the information
they're giving us there's so many
different ways this is just one way
right according to mainstream space
information here here's here's the Sun
right
and then here's earth right according to
them it takes one year to go around the
Sun right right so and when you're the
part of the earth that's facing the Sun
that's daytime right and this side the
side that I could look at that's
nighttime right because any time the Sun
that if the earth is a ball any time
it's facing the Sun it's daytime any
time so at nighttime we're actually not
look the Sun is on the up opposite side
we're looking at at this side of the
wall right right
this is let's say this is the universe
right here's the Sun right so at
nighttime we're looking on the other way
look at that way so in six months we're
looking that way mm-hmm right three more
months we're looking at with him so from
when the summit when the earth is over
here right there's no way we can see
those stars over there right there's
it's impossible right we got to look
through the Sun and then work there's no
way right we're looking at that side so
in six months we're over here we should
be looking at a complete opposite side
of the universe right right does that
make sense yeah but you don't you don't
you don't you know you see the same
stars the stars you don't you don't see
it completely do you see the Big Dipper
year round how's that possible well this
is the easiest one so there's always
something like girl you're trying to
hook up with and she's like oh there's
the Big Dipper you know it's always
there it's always and then the North
Star Polaris is always there what do we
know for sure about
about the planet and space because
anything that we have to take someone's
word for yeah in this argument in this
debate you gotta throw that out because
that's what the arguments about but
arguments about we don't trust [ __ ] that
we can't verify for ourselves so if
you're gonna get on your [ __ ] phone
and and and go to the nasa.gov website
and say look it says right here it's
true that's the whole point of this the
whole point of this is we don't trust
that [ __ ] that's like getting in an
argument with someone who's a
bible-thumper and he's always bringing
up Jesus quotes and you're like dude why
do you keep bringing up Jesus cuz I
don't believe in the Bible right what so
you know what I mean and he keeps
Pringles aw you're wrong look it says
right here in the Bible you can't bring
up the Bible me because I'm an atheist
right not me I'm just this an example
I'm not an atheist I do believe in God
but I'm just saying if you're gonna
argue with an atheist who doesn't
believe anything in the Bible and you
keep referencing the Bible you are the
Union yeah you are the idiot because
you're trying to have a real debate with
them you got to talk about [ __ ] that
ain't the Bible because you're talking
to someone who doesn't believe in the
Bible so you keep quoting the Bible
you're the [ __ ] [ __ ] so um it's the
same thing yes it's the same thing with
space yeah you know like we'll check
this out do you think so I had this idea
that so say we're starting to create
robots right do you think if those
robots became self-aware like we're
starting to become to whoever created us
or whatever is holding us do say if we
create a robot it's we have created
robots they start to become self-aware
do you think we would get rid of those
robots or do you think that we would let
them man I don't know I don't know man
I don't know what I don't know what to
think about artificial intelligence
because the people that are there's
people out there who make a living off
debunking conspiracy theories and
generally conspiracy theories are
anti-government
so there's people out there that's all
they do is debunk whatever it is and
push the official story yeah that's what
they do
those people are saying beware of
artificial intelligence yeah those are
the people that are saying that's what
we should really be worrying about so um
I tend to think like okay so we probably
don't have to worry about artificial
intelligence if they're if they're
saying worry if that's what they're
saying if they say worry about it I
think that's
fear-mongering I don't think I don't
think we're gonna have to worry about it
but I could be wrong the one thing we
have to worry about is them those are
DARPA dogs have you seen that black
mirror episode yeah when those dogs get
programmed to hunt you down Sheila I
think we have to worry about those DARPA
dogs I'm ready for that all right I'm
ready for that yeah honestly how many
bazookas oh dude look I think by in some
places man buying a gun is the new
voting you know yeah it's like people
are I think starting to really mistrust
especially the government and especially
the news everything yeah I think people
are starting to feel like they just want
to take things into their own hands more
yeah look at look at these false flags
going on all over the place people say
why do you think every school shooting
is a false flag is because they are god
damn it they are false flags you're just
too [ __ ] to see it you can't see it
how do we fight hypnotizes ation Eddie
real quick we're gonna get to a couple
questions I don't think there's any hope
you don't I don't think there's any hope
they're brilliant the people the Masters
of propaganda they're [ __ ] brilliant
they got they got it down dude they got
it down so what are we doing the
meantime to enjoy ourselves just enjoy
it enjoy your family enjoy I like to
talk about it yes I'm obsessed with I
like know that it should I'm obsessed
with finding out how we're being [ __ ]
yeah we're being [ __ ] every way you
could think about it's all over the
place mad propaganda a mad programming
on TV it's it's brilliant they're
getting the kids they get the kids into
space and dinosaurs quick oh yeah give
them that space and die so you know why
because by the time they're 15 there's
no way they're gonna question it's just
like religion you get a kid into
Catholicism he generally they're not
gonna question it by the time they're 16
17 they're like there's no way you're
gonna convince that kid that there isn't
a god yeah and that's the same thing why
is it so important to drown our kids in
in space man yeah face everywhere I
think God you go to the mall they got a
kid's shop it
the kids got NASA clothes on and [ __ ]
like that it's brilliant
I don't think there's anything we could
do about it and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be one of those guys that are
protesting with science I'm not gonna be
a guy that's leading a revolution I just
want peace but I like talking about it
yeah I'm gonna keep talking about it but
there
nothing we could do about it look it
look like Hillary Clinton look at all
the evil [ __ ] that she's done nothing
happening to her like a Bill Clinton
nothing happening to him that they got
some they got like they got see people
think people think scale it don'ts yeah
like they got dead bodies all around
there's a continent it's a mean now to
talk about I make sure Hillary yeah
found out you're gonna get suicide
by getting suicide people know what that
means and it's not suicide
it's a fake suicide where they shut your
[ __ ] ass up people that speak up
people that go after them too much and
they get killed look at the I'm Chris
Cornell from Soundgarden and Chester
from Lincoln Park coincidentally they
were both into fighting child
trafficking hmm hardcore they got that
like Chris Cornell and his wife had a
the Chris and Vicky Foundation yeah all
about and they go they're gone and
they're going to gone but what what do
they get by eliminating us who think who
begin to take back our will and our free
thinking what do they they don't want
they don't want to get thrown in jail
that's what it is when I mean in a sense
that that's a sign me know the fact that
people are being suicided and the fact
that it's the dark arts people people
are being bribed the fact that that's
going on means that damn if they got to
bribe people they got a suicide people
they're worried about some [ __ ] so
they're not totally immune to these are
them as we yes they must not be totally
immune to us figuring it out yeah that's
that's a little sign because you know I
have faith generally I'm thinking and
two people are two hypnotized I don't
know they're hypnotized too many people
are like you [ __ ] idiot you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like dude I just don't trust
mainstream information I dread that said
you want to trust it go ahead don't call
me an idiot I think you're a [ __ ]
idiot yeah for trusting criminals you
know they're criminals right now think
to yourself you know the world is run by
criminals you get you trust them you're
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah now I'm one of
the questions so say we we that there
are robots that start to get artificial
intelligence right and that if robots
became self-aware that we would shut the
robots down do you think that some of
the robots
would pretend that they weren't
self-aware so that we wouldn't know so
they wouldn't get done suicided if we
get suicide about us see what I'm saying
until it was too late for them to all I
don't know a little too late for us I
don't know that much about well if they
did yeah I'm not too sure about it I'm
just trying you know what I like I said
I'm turning down conspiracy theory shows
but you know what you better want this I
wouldn't want this whole podcast easily
with without talking about conspiracy
yeah I know you would easily yes that's
why I wanted to talk about so we brought
that up you know that's that's you know
that's part of what I do every now and
then I mean I'm doing that tinfoil hat
comedy you know it's Sam triple oh dude
you know what I mean so so so but you
know what we're like making fun of
conspiracy theories but you guys are
talking about it though to like you guys
are that you guys are talking about it
and it's growing that's my thing DC do
you not feel like sometimes like you're
on the horizon may be of some people
helping people think well if you go to
one of the tinfoil hat comedy shows I'll
like smash flattered you know what I
mean yeah right because you you if you
when you preach in conspiracy theories
it's hard to be funny yeah I'm just
trying to be funny and you know there's
you know it's called tinfoil hat can
comedy night but really like Sam does
another show called a chaos comedy we'll
put the links right below right first
link so does that mean the comedy all
the comics gotta have chaos in their act
no no just called chaos comedy so Tim
for hat comedy yeah there's gonna be
some conspiracy theory stuff in there
but everyone does conspiracy theory
stuff like Dave Chappelle talking about
the origins of aids like in his car
that's conspiracy theory like it's gone
because they said monkeys gave us aids
you know art is the [ __ ] monkey you
know what I mean that's some of the
greatest you know areare that's
conspiracy theory gotta go back and
forth yeah so naturally naturally
stand-up comedy is gonna have some
conspiracy theory stuff in it you know
so we do that but I do bits on stuff
have nothing to do conspiracy theories
no I want to see some of that I know you
and Sam we're going on tour as well
sometime this year right or next year
well we're gonna be in San Francisco at
Cobbs Jiu Friday June first and then
June 2nd on that Saturday we're going to
do punchline
at in Sacramento you can get your
tickets at Live Nation calm
if those shows sell out if those show
sellout then Live Nation's gonna set up
a mini tour for us they like the idea do
whole poster the telling man I'm a huge
fan of Sam I love Sam Sam's awesome and
and for that San Francisco show we're
doing a little contest thing with Sam's
idea great great idea the person who
brings the most people the most guess is
gonna get to be on a podcast we're gonna
do after the show we're gonna do a
special part yeah for the person who
brought the most people we're trying to
sell that place out look we'll push that
a ton we have a couple of questions that
get it from gasps some questions from
guests and also a question for you too
regarding conspiracy theories so I'm
kind of with you with a lot of stuff and
I'll be honest with you I'm not fully on
board with flatterer
that's a hard one it was all right I was
violently opposed to it I was mad at
people that would bring it up and that's
normal ever everybody that's in the flat
earth mm-hmm
it was very hard for them to get into it
and admit it took like a year and a half
for them to admit well first it was
black dudes basically I feel like that
right now I was violently opposed to it
but the one thing about flattered at the
punch and flattered on YouTube you're
gonna get all the debunkers like why is
there so many people working against it
it's crazy
it's a say it's it's they're doing the
exact same thing the flattered that they
do to 9/11 JFK iran-contra they got
people producing debunking video yeah
why are you doing that if it's so sighs
no it's it's like you should ask
yourself why is there a debate about it
how is there a debate still and this
time with the internet why are people
and people are there's so many people
that are afraid to admit that they're
looking into Flat Earth because the
amount of ridicule you get yeah I mean I
was I was quiet about it but I was
against it I was trying to you know
people kept coming up to have you have
you looked in the flatterer than like
[ __ ] yeah you're crazy it's like a
couple years ago yeah [ __ ] Joe I was on
Joe's podcast and he would bring it up
goes dude people are so dumb there's
some people out there still believe the
earth is flat I'm like what the [ __ ] are
they really there's people like that and
this was just a few years ago and now
here and now you're yeah now you're then
I kept trying to debunk it I would
arguments with people and that's the
typical story everyone's trying to
debunk it then the one thing that made
me realize something was wrong as I
always believed that the moon the moon
landings were faked and that's what I
thought NASA was I thought NASA was in
charge of the moon missions I didn't
think they were in charge of all space
information I thought that was all these
scientists everywhere and they're there
figuring out you know [ __ ] about the
universe and um once I once once like
and I was looking into it and I realized
oh should all these pictures of Earth
from space they're all CGI composites
and NASA admits it they got you know
what we take the images and all they we
take this information strips and then we
get an artist to put together like wait
a minute you guys aren't even getting
real pictures the [ __ ] earth from
space I go ahead the picture where's the
bootlegs yeah where's the [ __ ] space
bootlegs and you get that you get the
earth on your iPhone that's the default
the default picture I got I had looked
at Earth everyday on my iPhone I see
that guy how you gonna tell me the earth
is flat I seen so the guy said go
because I got I got a math master's in
engineering look into it and so I did
and I realized damn then I started
tracing these pictures back to NASA then
I realized wait a min asseh NASA is
controlling all our space information I
go NASA does that I thought they just
did the moon in the Space Shuttle yeah
dude they've been around for 60 years
I've been to the moon allegedly four
times six times yes 600 they destroyed
all the technology come on man dude
that's the force if that was a business
you'd be like yeah you know what they
had to say they destroyed it what are
they gonna say what else they gonna say
they gonna let people they destroyed all
the video the raw video footage the raw
audio footage all the telemetry data
which tracked where they were in space
oh that's gone because there's no way
that they could even leave that for us
to really look at yeah and I look I
think the biggest thing is to think and
try and be brave in your thoughts
because you know I mean I grew up you
know with you know a lot of Christian
influence around me and stuff and at
first it was scary for me to start
thinking about other things because I
didn't want to because it was just in my
makeup that made me feel like oh it was
a little bit wrong but now man I love to
think about it you know if I'm not
thinking about it then what I'm just
wasting a lot of my time here I'm just
going to accept everything for like
complete face value without questioning
it just seems ridiculous to me that
people are all on board with putting up
memes that say question authority you
know
all no-one's like say no don't question
authority nobody says that nobody would
ever say don't questionable or I mean I
go back to the middle monkeys man like I
you know I I believe that we're closely
related to and that we have a lot of the
same stuff but I've never been to the
zoo and been like you know [ __ ] you know
I miss the old neighborhood like I don't
have any feeling like that in my body
you know like if I see the monkeys at
the zoo I'm not like oh that's the old
gang you know I feel any [ __ ]
connection when you break down like
evolution and Darwin and Isaac Newton
although there are Freemason Jesuits man
all the major astronomers Jesuit Jesu
it's all part of the plan they control
like the Vatican has the most powerful
telescope you know what it's name is
Lucifer Jesus the Vatican's it's a dark
art their telescope had no is named
Lucifer it's almost like they're [ __ ]
with us they are man how you gonna call
Lucifer man I thought I thought you guys
hated that month what the [ __ ] going
on over you call the Lucifer and then we
don't see anything that they're saying
come you don't show us what you're
looking at yeah a couple vatican hero
shows in our algorithm Vatican Jake I'll
never forget done me and Jo and we
[ __ ] balls deep into space and [ __ ]
back like in 2001 we're watching a
documentary on the VLT telescope and
that stands for a very large telescope
VLT it was a documentary about it like
in 2001 and they were building it
somewhere in South America where it's
you know 360 days it's clear or the
atmosphere it's a the perfect place for
a gigantic the most powerful telescope
ever never the documentary was about
building it they weren't it wasn't done
yet it was three giant mirrors that were
gonna be linked together through
software through computer software and
they said by 2005 they're gonna be able
to take shot they're gonna be able to
take shots of the moon like right on the
ground like we're gonna be able to see
the and nothing yeah and where is it
since 2005 and it's 2018 there's no shot
where's the shot as a nod am
especially if it's a rag on the moon
let's see the flat yeah let's see that
they're not showing [ __ ] on the moon
dang Sheila Mecca well they also said -
this is this is something I heard that
whenever they took off that the that the
shuttle knocked the flag down and that's
why you can't see it that's why what a
great excuse oh yeah that's look at the
moon look at the moon like the
conspiracy theory is that the moonlight
the moon is its own luminary it's it's
not a ball of sand it's actually it's
like a like a nighttime Sun it's a light
and the crazy the craziest thing about
the moon and and and before I got into
flatter the crate I could never wrap my
brain around how if the moon is orbiting
around us and it's a ball we why do we
always see the exact same side and they
say it's a synchronous orbit because
it's like holding hands or someone in
training but still even if it's a
synchronous orbit the after a while it
would move a little bit eventually we
would see the [ __ ] back of it but we
never see the back year after year
decade after decade millennia after
millennia it's the same side of the Moon
it's the same face it doesn't even move
like a little a little bit you would
think yeah I mean listen I mean even
just some of the stuff it's like first
of all Pluto that's what they talking
about at um growing up and then suddenly
15 years ago Oh Pluto doesn't exist
member that Pluto wasn't [ __ ] real
with the [ __ ] they're saying there's a
bunch of Pluto so they can't count Pluto
as a planet yeah they can't find out
they'd have to count that that it's it's
crazy and then the speed thing it's like
oh we're spinning at this and we're
going this the numbers almost sound like
something a kid would say yeah you know
yeah 60 million seven hundred Julianne
yeah thirty-seven about the
International Space Station supposedly
is going 17,000 miles an hour
seventeen you guys are supposed you guys
dock on that [ __ ] four times a
year you guys said a cargo ship
yeah with with app scientists
international scientists that you're
gonna yeah four times a year you're not
you're docking on something that's going
17,000 miles an hour yet there's no
footage of it
there's no footage and the one thing
that will prove that the earth is round
the one thing it's really easy people
say man
you need to start a good witnessing what
is the proof it's really easy people
always come up with this crazy [ __ ] I
start a GoFundMe go to the edge raise
this money go to the edge fly get on a
rocket fly it see for yourself you
wouldn't even believe it you saw her
yourself if you want to spend all you
have to spend is $17.99 $17 go to Best
Buy mm-hmm buy a [ __ ] go poke a GoPro
camera put it on one of those goddamn
scientists that you [ __ ] that go four
times a year put it on one of those
scientists I want an uncut video of them
going into the rocket going even if it
takes 17 hours I'll watch the whole
thing taking off
uncut docking onto the International
Space Station getting off and then
looking back at Earth if you could do
that in one shot I will shut the [ __ ] up
it's not what we bring to the edge with
Eddie go to Best Buy $17.99 we don't
need a GoFundMe now shut the [ __ ] up
with that all right so I this actually
brings up to what I wanted to ask you
and what's preventing me from going all
on board with Flat Earth is that you
know when you go on YouTube you know
there's a lot of people with too much
time and money on their hands and
they're buying weather the boiler
balloons attaching GoPro cameras to it
or just any cameras and launching it up
into space and if you watch that footage
I watch it yeah okay there's no
curvature well no but because some of
them don't go high enough there is this
is what I know exactly yeah this most
GoPro cameras have fisheye
so you could tell that really quick so a
lot of people go look I could see the
curvature goes dude that is obviously
fisheye lens so the ones that go up
without the fisheye lens they go up
they've been balloons a bunch of them go
up you could watch it on YouTube the
ones that don't have fisheye lens they
go up a hundred and ten thousand feet a
hundred and ten thousand feet a hundred
and twenty-one thousand feet they go up
there and there's zero curve and it was
brought to neil degrasse tyson's
attention my ass he says it's on video -
they said Neil because Neil is one of
their puppets yeah I don't trust him
exactly totally he's one he's had part
of the club they go we need a scientist
who's a good talker and he's funny and
charismatic they got he's an actor that
guy's an actor he's like Bill Nye the
Science Guy
those are actors they're trying to push
the science agenda but anyways so when I
asked Neil Neil deGrasse Tyson they go
how how come with these amateur balloons
we're not seeing any curvature at 120
1000 feet and Neil deGrasse Tyson said
that's not high enough you need to go
weigh hard core the earth is so big
that's what he said
but then they got all these people all
these people say dude look I get on a
plane and look out a window you could
see the curb but dude that's 35,000 feet
and it if neil degrasse tyson is saying
at a hundred and twenty-one thousand
feet
you're still not high enough and that's
the max for these balloons they can't
get any higher if he's saying you need
to go higher to see the curb
then how the [ __ ] are people saying they
see it at 35,000 miles on a plane it
doesn't make any sense makes that does
not make any sense if you can explain
that Neil deGrasse Tyson your old boy
your own boy said that [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying even like a patsy
you create one they're gonna mess up
every now and then they're not gonna get
it alright yeah what I'm saying there
know what you know why the right then
and I'm Joe Rogan me and him we're
having her Flat Earth discussion and
battles and debates and I say you know
what we could handle this you know this
is handless one for once in a frock why
don't we get Eric do bang he's the best
flattering there's a lot of shield yeah
are you talking about him oh no poor
Eric Dubay vs. Neil deGrasse Tyson on
JRE oh well that would destroy that
would destroy the Internet right and Joe
was all for just a we could [ __ ] make
that happen and he contacts Neil
deGrasse Tyson he goes dude I contracted
Neil we're gonna do it I contact Eric
Tobago it's [ __ ] happening
and right when right when Joe Rogan even
put it on a schedule he said like for
February he's talked about it on his
Podesta he's talked about her on his
podcast in this and then right when it
was announced Eric Dubay his YouTube
channel gets deleted mm-hmm it gets
deleted I'm not crazy but he still wants
to do it
so so now tears above Eric Dubay if you
go to his YouTube channel and he's made
a video going Joe when's this gonna
happen look you put it on your schedule
you talked about it on your podcast
when's it gonna hit on neil degrasse Joe
wants to make it happen the problem is
Neil deGrasse Tyson he don't want none
Eric Dubay you know he could no no
there's no way he's gonna debate as I
said ask for it just that that little
demonstration of we write how we
see he doesn't to answer that every six
months there should be a different set
of stars completely different but they
can't answer that one they can't answer
that one for people to think that's my
biggest thing man people think we're
shooting through the universe at a
million miles an hour and spinning in a
circle and gravity and gone and the
whole thing without gravity that
heliocentric model that mainstream model
falls apart gravity is what holds
everything together I think about this
if people asked like they say well
children will ask this well if the earth
is spinning up at a thousand miles an
hour why aren't the oceans being flinged
off and the answer is gravity is holding
gravities at wild yeah taffy yeah
gravity is holding oceans to it right
now gravity is holding skyscrapers
otherwise skyscrapers were throwing up
oceans would fling yeah right if this
force is so strong it's so strong that
it's holding oceans to it how come it
doesn't [ __ ] with a helium balloon
there's a helium balloon is that
anti-gravity yes know what it is that
the other conspiracy theory with gravity
is that and I didn't make this up
gravity has never been proven it's never
been measured Isaac Newton came up with
it and it it it doesn't hold water
literally if if if the reason why a
helium balloon Rises and doesn't get
stuck to the ground is because helium is
less dense than the air you think is
just our weight it's a density and
buoyancy think about it you throw a rock
into the ocean it sinks to the ground
you throw a tennis ball into the ocean
it just floats because the air inside
that tennis ball is less dense than the
water anything that's less dense goes up
anything that's more dense than the
medium that holds it sinks there's a
density hold a density thing how come
how come if you if thing about this but
what makes density the force on it right
the gravity what was the question
like what creates like dense he like
what makes one thing dense and one what
I'm saying is I'm no scientist all right
no but I'm just as afraid as common man
yeah I'm thinking why you would
like 250 pound man say you know Ray
Lewis is yeah but would it be easier for
him to hold a baby stuck to the ground
or another 250 pound man
awaiting me yes that's common sense
right yeah he's got all this force
against a baby
gravity is has the force to hold ocean's
stuck to it yet it can't hold a
butterfly stuck to the butterfly we
should be stuck to the [ __ ] ground
like a like some kind of magnet but yeah
we're not but oceans are being held and
if gravity is holding oceans to it then
there must be gravity must be fighting
the inertia of that 1000 mile an hour
spin right so there's a battle between
the inertia flinging the water off and
the gravity holding it together
you would think more towards it or a
little more maybe a splash but here is
their evidence of this this battle
battle between the inertia and the
gravity there is no battle this should
it should be like the ocean should be
like leaning to one side kind of all the
time you know kind of doable yeah and
and water you can't find it if we were
truly a ball with a circumference of
25,000 miles an hour or 25,000 miles
sorry you got to lead us though man yeah
but but if it's true then the the ball
should Bend at 6,000 feet per every
hundred miles so we should be able to
measure the curve of oceans every
hundred miles there should be six six
thousand feet of curvature yet you could
go on YouTube and hear there's a there's
a video on a US Navy quartermaster he's
a quartermaster she works on like
[ __ ] battleships and he says you on
YouTube just YouTube US naval
quartermaster and he explains because
there's no way there could be six
thousand feet of curvature at a hundred
miles because they're targeting and
imaging ships had a hundred miles it
would be impossible if there was a six
thousand feet curve right there was no
there would be no way they could target
it there should be six thousand feet of
curvature at 100 miles
so yeah and as it yeah and then if if
the world is a ball with at with the
circumference of 25,000 miles then every
hundred miles or should be six thousand
feet of dip it and and also when you're
on a plane
you should be every five minutes you
should be dipping dip in the nose dip in
the nose so why on it otherwise you're
just going right into space yeah but
they never dip their nose they just
they're just hovering over a plane yeah
at that they're just keeping there's so
many there's if the dirt goes on forever
yeah and the crazy thing is there's
websites out there that like you heard
of the Flat Earth Society the flatter
societies where like Obama is directing
everybody he brings up because this is
not a meeting of the Flat Earth Society
so he's sending everybody to the Flat
Earth Society which is a bunk website
yeah nobody that's a true flat earther
has gone through they bypass the Flat
Earth Society because if your versa if
yet exactly if your first introduction
to the Flat Earth like you're curious
like everyone keeps talking about the
flattery and then you hear about Flat
Earth Society because they they pump
that up they want to send you there you
go and you you punch in Flat Earth on
Google you punch in Flat Earth on Google
right now the first thing is gonna come
up is the Flat Earth Wikipedia which is
all controlled and it looks ridiculous
and then the Flat Earth Society is right
there it's gonna direct flatter Society
on the first page all over the place so
if you go to flatter society first
you're never gonna be [ __ ] laughs yeah
because right they're gonna they want to
send you first and so you know the world
think for yourself you cannot take you
know if you gotta be wild if you're
curious about Flat Earth there's a lot
of people out there there's a lot of
great information the YouTube channel
beyond the imaginary curve great [ __ ]
Eric Dubay is YouTube channel great [ __ ]
those links in yeah the great great [ __ ]
we want to get a question or two real
quick Eddie about some of our listeners
I appreciate it man I appreciate the
information I appreciate you having an
open mind man that's yeah we rushing
things when I taught when I talked to
like Sam Tripoli he's not you know
conspiracy theorist we we have such
distrust of the government you can come
up to me and say dude I was on YouTube
last night it turns out the government's
[ __ ] these people like that I
wouldn't even me [ __ ]
evidence yeah you know what I mean I
wouldn't need I would just believe you
it's like you coming up to me and saying
you know I don't want to say any names
but let's just say this a person that's
a notorious [ __ ]
yeah I shouldn't or she [ __ ] everybody
right right if you came up to me cuz do
you know she [ __ ] [ __ ] Kanye West
over like a night and I would be like I
wouldn't I wouldn't say where's the
proof
yeah of course she probably did she's
warning if she didn't she's still a
[ __ ]
yeah you know what I mean yeah that's
how I look at the guttering so when you
come up and you say hey dude the
government's do this was shady before
they're here I'd be like if it makes
sense to me just a little bit I would
not need any evidence you know I mean
there's a science team at the University
of Alaska did a study on Tower seven to
prove once and for all then it was a
controlled demo university to ask you
could it's official they go yeah I was a
controlled demo those so much evidence
of thermo nano-thermite and explosive
stuff people needed a [ __ ] science
team to prove the tower seven was a
controlled demo I didn't need no goddamn
science yeah I didn't need it all I need
do
there was only two explanations for
Tower seven either it was a control demo
or that video the five angles we got of
that control demo were all CGI that's it
if they would have came at me and said
that [ __ ] ain't real that CGI
that's not real yeah they don't be then
we down to analyze a goddamn it looks
real [ __ ] to me but okay but nobody's
saying that the five different angles of
Tower seven falling at freefall speed
collapse completely in its own footprint
nine seconds no one's saying that that
was CGI so it of course it's a control
demo yeah I didn't need an S people need
this is our people need they need that
it would be like yeah it would be like
I'm um like they did a study that group
of scientists is starting to prove that
alcohol I increases sexual libido
mm-hmm did you need to read them I
didn't need to read that you know what I
mean it's ridiculous right so hypnotized
people I mean it of quality of course
like more obvious just why don't you
want people trust whatever little
instinct I have left yeah I'd love to do
I love to do an episode on a couple of
these specific ideas I'm gonna get two
couple questions I want to give you a
couple things too we got this one of our
sponsors called Ridge
awesome yeah and they make this is
awesome uh this wallet too that they
make is really dope and actually use one
of those dude I use one too awesome bro
they make really cool stuff put that
initially I was you know given a little
skeptical look now I can't believe I
waited this long it's nice stuff man but
this is their wallet yeah we have a list
of questions that sent in so don't
figure let's just do a quick fire on
some of our quickfire oh nice okay so at
tits a guy on Instagram said if you had
the opportunity to know the truth about
all conspiracy theories but you had to
get get to quit jiu-jitsu forever would
you take that in any capacity couldn't
compete you couldn't coach
you couldn't even watch your own well
I'm almost 50 years old and I'm barely
you know I'm better today Eddie we're
talking today uh but I had to give up
jiu-jitsu yeah but you know it all know
we go and do it all right so we got sage
asks us what would you tell yourself if
you can go back to when you were 21 what
kind of advice would you give you 21
year old self I wouldn't give myself any
advice because that would change the
course of history and I don't want my
like that I don't want my I love my life
the way it is because everything led up
to my son any kind of change would would
would probably make it so that I didn't
have them so have you want everything
perfect have some of your have your
dreams come true you feel like Eddie and
in ways maybe you didn't expect them to
but they've come but like do you feel
like that in your life like you like
you've live a fulfilled life yes I do
that's cool it's it's you know I was
brainwashed with the whole rock star
thing so and now the more I learn about
how the music business really works um
I'm happy that my music sucks I'm happy
that I didn't get signed
because if first you know that
one-in-a-million chance that I was able
to write good music and it got signed
and I got big dude could've been how
dude I would
at 23 you know if they would have said
you know we're gonna blow you the [ __ ]
up we're gonna give you that mansion
we're gonna give you everything you just
gotta suck a couple executive producers
dicks mm-hmm
I would have thought about it I would be
like how long do I gotta suck for ya you
know what I mean I would have thought
about it like um what kind of man can I
see the mansion first yeah and I think I
would say you got to put them on [ __ ]
in my name first
once it's in my name and I have the
papers to the house with the copy deity
you notify it then I'd be like okay yeah
like this is the mansion every window
today see yeah we'd have to sit down and
have some negotiation but I would
probably [ __ ] do it yeah oh dude I
would've did I would've did porn but
what if I would have the opportunity
they add me hook line and sinker I want
I wanted to be this David Lee Roth Hugh
Hefner but you know watch the star you
know what I mean I would have I would I
would have if someone wanted directed me
and I would have did part like I get to
[ __ ] [ __ ] and get paid for Vogue yeah
yeah I was [ __ ] lost I was a lost as
susceptible yeah yeah I would have done
I would have done anything to make it so
imagine how many people like that are
out there
you want anything so so now now I look
at the music business as I always
wondered why most music sucks and why
most movies suck like movies this is the
best week of [ __ ] to do movies suck
now I realize what the entertainment
business is the entertainment business
isn't about exposing talent
it's about propaganda it's a different
way to brainwash people it's just
another way it's when you're building an
empire you gotta have control of
everything the sciences energy food
water entertainment it's all part of the
mixed entertainment isn't something that
grows [ __ ] organically and it's all
about entertainment and and pure art has
nothing to do with that [ __ ] yeah and
nothing to do with that [ __ ] it's an
another way to manipulate to brainwash
to control that's why movies suck yeah
the only movies that are good or every
now and then a good movie comes out it's
like an indie movie or something because
I get to awake who they don't want us
they want to keep us love the big
blockbuster movies get the 50 so they
[ __ ] everything with the rock and it
almost it's like carrying
and harder on his shoulders movies suck
because so but I'm not trying to be good
that's right they're trying to morals
they're trying to mold us into wine it's
almost like they think us they have us
pin - all right we're gonna wrap it up
because we got to get finished but what
is uh you have one more question for you
so we got one final question to end this
but when we gues gonna be about my music
I hate answering questions about my
we're gonna play well you know what I do
have an album out of here if you're we
will if you're weird about music go to
my YouTube channel and punch in mix
flick of death and devotion it's a 15
song album it's not just one band it's
three of the Bands that I produce and
I'm in as well all in one album all cut
to my favorite movies like Scarface The
Crow The Shining I took all my favorite
movies and made music videos out of them
so mix flick of death and devotion check
it out dude that's almost a perfect
story of your life mix flick of death
and devotion it almost describes like
like I'm not even joking like a lot of
the things you talked about today you
know yeah like just a total mix movies
entertainment industry music almost
dying luck in yeah it's a good thing to
put on my cat you and your friends come
over and you don't really want to watch
anything you want to talk yeah it's a
good thing to put on cuz you get like a
four-minute version of Scarface a
formative in the city a four-minute
version of momento you don't have to pay
attention you can watch there's music
going on it's a conversational piece
yeah it's like it's something you put it
like in the background at a party or
something but that you love having
around just like Eddie Bravo you know
all right so let's end on this final
question thirty something super mom
wants to know where should a beginner
out-of-shape mom start when wanting to
get into jiu-jitsu you're any local
jiu-jitsu gym you know 99% of jiu-jitsu
gyms cater to absolute beginners most
most of the people that pay the rent at
jiu-jitsu schools are beginners you know
most of my classes at my school in
downtown LA are for beginners you know
there's just a few advanced class yeah
classes there most of them is for
newbies you know most jiu-jitsu schools
are like that you know you can go to ten
planet JJ calm
locations I got about a hundred
worldwide a hundred yeah
Wow impressive man that has really in
from us you know from a kid that you
know came from your background you've
had an impressive story so far man I had
the one thing I learned I want to close
on this one thing I learned is that
cliche when you least expect it expect
it that's so goddamn true in my life I
always expected rock stardom
I never expected jiu-jitsu notoriety
never I mean when I wasn't I didn't
start doing jiu-jitsu till I left home
and people people when when I when I
went to Abu Dhabi and tapped out Hoyle
er I didn't win the tournament I got
beat the next one when I came back my
mom goes how was Brazil you know and I
go yeah I beat her the Gracie but you
know I lost my next match because it's
okay baby maybe next time you know she
didn't understand the significance you
know of a beating [ __ ] the Gracie and
none of them didn't know one and I never
went home for Christmas and bragged
about my jiu-jitsu yeah they were just
like someone at work told me another
book [ __ ] jiu-jitsu like my uncle
would tell me that and then my cousin
would say hey do you do like a martial
art yeah what am I good so one of my
friends is like a big fan of yours like
what's going on so they found out slowly
and they had a hard time believing it
like people that know me from jiu-jitsu
have a hard time believing that I'm a
legit music musician that's right they
have a hard time seeing that but the
people that I grew up with they have a
hard time seeing the jiu-jitsu they got
you're a little [ __ ] how does the [ __ ]
did you pull that oh my god oh no I'm
like it was an accident I don't know
have you said I don't know have you see
you surprised yourself I I didn't expect
it's it's when you expect something
ain't gonna happen
expectations or resentments waiting to
happen that's what I've always thought
don't expect anything you know when
people want I coach people they're like
they're about to fight that was I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'm supposed to when I train
too hard so I'm gonna [ __ ] you ain't
gonna take that from me yeah I'm like
I'd like the time I go you know what
you're just fooling
you're just filling yourself up with
some [ __ ] just say you're gonna try
your best you trained hard anything
could happen
but I'm gonna do my best
that's the reality of what's going on if
you're if you expect to win and and you
know you're gonna win it's probably a
mismatch yeah that's a real fight
anything it happened you can't guarantee
[ __ ] guarantee your purse then into your
purse yeah don't wants to forget and see
their first cuz everybody knows deep
down inside
anything could happen anything so um I
like that it's a great it's a great it's
it's true man you follow what you truly
love without any thought about making
money dad that is the truth because you
got to do when people say if you had a
billion dollars what would you do that's
what you should do figure that out
what do you what are you doing and
you're not what are you doing for the
absolute love of it yeah whether there's
money that's eventually you do that so
much and without even thinking that's
gonna just be your career yeah you're
gonna make money out of it somehow you
know what I mean like if you just love
snowboarding all day you just want to
sleep you truly love it you're gonna do
it all the time and if you do it all the
time you're gonna be really good at it
and you're gonna find a way to make
money will you loved music so much and
eventually it led you into being happy
and it's still a part of your life yep
even if it's not the you know I mean
it's even it's not if it's not the part
that people see every day from you today
it's still like I think that that's even
a unique way of your own story it's like
you just kind of followed what you loved
and it led you to being happy yeah you
know it did it led to my son and my
marriage and my family and that's the
most important thing dude you got to
come back and I want to break down the
make maybe some some specific like you
know things that have happened in
history and specific things that would
go back to look at I mean I know we
talked about some flatter stuff today
which when you think about it has been
around to the beginning of time people
thinking if the earth is flat around you
know that's something news they're not
know it's Oh they've been suppressing it
if there's been books yeah but
scientists to put out books I'm like
Samuel Rowbotham read his but there's a
lot of books go on dude this is all
[ __ ] what they're telling us back in
an 1800s 1800s Early 1900s it's always
been around yeah it's not like some new
thing that Eric Dubay made up yeah it's
it's always better oh it's it's always
been a debate yeah are we are on a ball
or a wee ant some [ __ ] flat plane of
some so
like nobody knows there's no proof of
anything all we're saying is all the
[ __ ] you're telling us that [ __ ] don't
die don't fly right don't it don't make
sense well it shouldn't just fly it
should be questioned yes of course it
should be questioned you're you're a
smart man
I'm learning a little bit as I go man
due to such a pleasure to have you here
today man thank you really appreciate it
bro such an inspiration this is one of
the funnest podcast I've ever had oh
good welcome so I'm so happy yeah
totally our audience is like fun you
know like sometimes it's funny and
sometimes it's cool but our audience is
like you know they just love what we're
doing here we're doing a lot of neat
stuff and having you come in and just
making us think you know because
sometimes I don't want to it's hard to
do it yeah sometimes I don't even I want
to just watch some mindless [ __ ] on
Netflix I'm like I'm like looking for
anything and by conspiracy I don't want
to because sometimes I'm in the mood get
on my Apple TV and go right to YouTube
yeah let's do it
and then sometimes I'm like dude I want
to watch some bold I want to watch
Gotham you know what I mean just
nonsense with the crazy thing about
Gotham is it's so much it's crazy
comical as it is yeah it's very there's
a lot of truth in it yeah the way I
don't know you watch Gotham but the way
that cities run and it's basically
Gotham is the most corrupt city ever and
it's there's a lot of truth to it but
I'm you know I wanted to watch South
Park yeah take it easy yeah I don't want
to think about conspiracy theory not
always and that's what's happening to us
people think of me people know me more
as a conspiracy theorist there ivenna
jujitsu guy now oh my god I want that
yeah booking you I was like listen I
don't like how sometimes when you get
booked on the show and people kind of
attack you I feel like it's a little bit
disrespectful and there's so much more
to you than conspiracy theories that's
why I wanted to open up with the music
you keep evolving that you keep evolving
yeah we appreciate it we'll do it again
soon it hell yeah hell yeah all right
thanks so much man we'll put the legs
you done on Sam tripolis podcast tinfoil
hat I did it one time didn't we got to
talk to one of the investigators of the
Steven Avery case which was pretty
fascinating which one we have a murderer
oh [ __ ] watch it like that
about that yeah come on an episode when
you guys have it if you hell yeah I love
Jim I love saying I'm not doing my
podcast anymore I'm like like I said I I
did like maybe 60 or 70 episodes and at
at I I don't I repeat myself a lot and
and people get annoyed with that and on
a podcast you have to repeat yourself
right I always feel like when I tell the
same story again that I'm annoying
everybody so that I'm like I thought I
thought you know what I'm only gonna
talk on someone else's podcast on my own
podcast I'm like just I don't like
repeating myself yeah plus I don't want
to be known it was turning into a
conspiracy theory podcast right and I'm
like and meanwhile I'm try to have
musicians on and not talk about it you
know I'm trying to just yeah I'm
constantly struggling and fighting with
it I am obsessed with knowing the truth
I'm obsessed with knowing how we're
being lied to and manipulated and
brainwashed and programmed I'm obsessed
with that but at the same time I don't
want to get too crazy about it because I
don't I just want to enjoy my life you
know and I think too many people are
hypnotized they're really to do anything
about it you know yeah I'm not trying to
be this revolutionary trying to change
the world I'm just speaking my mind and
you may end up as one though I don't
want to be I don't want any I'll shut I
want to shut the [ __ ] up I don't know
you may end up as one man I'd follow
your brother thank you sir all right
well uh thank you for being you ready
and we'll talk to you guys soon and my
mind is somewhere else but when I found
it I'll patch up where it's been now I'm
just floating on the breeze and I feel
up
like these leaves I must be the star oh
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my my flower I can feel it